1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Ciao Herr Moderator, Ihre Aufgabe ist es, diese Sendung anzukündigen.
Ja, dann kündige ich doch mal diese Sendung an. Schönen guten Abend, diese Sendung ist angekündigt. Das ist Chaosradio 49, Andy, Frank und Fefe im Studio. An den Knöpfen sitzt der Holger. Das Thema sagen am besten die, die sich damit auskennen, nämlich nicht ich.
Genau, wir wollen heute nämlich über Radio reden.
Und über Fernsehen.
Ja, aber hauptsächlich eigentlich über Radio und über die Zukunft.
Genau.
Und Internet wie immer.
Natürlich, weil das Radio einfach so, das habt ihr jeden Tag hier, das hört ihr auch jetzt gerade. Wir wollen heute aber auch vor allem über Internetradio reden.
Und über die Technologie, die eventuell euch möglich macht, bald euren eigenen Radiosender auch zu machen und euch nicht mehr diesen Unsinn hier anhören zu müssen.
Genau.
Das wäre katastrophal.
Und schon, kriegen wir jetzt Ärger mit Fritz, ja?
Weiß ich nicht, Fritz? Ist grad nicht hier.
Haben wir ja nochmal Glück gehabt. Also, aber mal im Ernst. Es geht eigentlich um Multicast, oder?
Ja, genau.
Also es geht hauptsächlich um Multicast. Wir haben ein paar schöne Meldungen für euch mitgebracht. Wir machen auch nicht nur Multicast die ganze Zeit. Wir erwähnen noch ein bisschen am Rande, was es denn für Verfahren gibt. Multicast ist ein reines Transportverfahren. Das heißt, da ist noch nicht geklärt, in welcher Form das Audiosignal jetzt übertragen wird. Muss man vorher komponieren, damit es über eine Modemleitung überhaupt sinnvoll ist. Es ist sinnvoll, ein voller Signal zu kriegen oder nicht nur Telefonqualität.
Und bevor wir dann in genau diese technischen Details einsteigen, werden wir euch auch nochmal erzählen, wie das überhaupt alles im Anfang losgeht. Das heißt, was ihr euch installieren müsst an Programmen, um auf Ihr Radio zu hören und auch mal ein bisschen selbst rumzuspielen und einfach Radiosender im Internet zu machen.
Und vor allem, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Genau.
Die Musik, die wir hören, hast du Andi übrigens aus Moskau mitgebracht. Wir können euch die Gehörer nicht sagen, um was es sich da handelt. Weil wir nicht in der Lage sind, Chirilisch zu lesen. Aber vielleicht treiben wir noch den ein oder anderen auf heute Abend hier im Sender.
Wir haben uns überlegt, dass wir auch erst einmal ein bisschen Update geben wollten, was ist eigentlich in den letzten vier Wochen passiert, seit ihr das letzte Mal Chaosradio hören konntet.
Genau, da gab es nämlich so ein paar komische Sachen im Internet, die da passiert sind, wo plötzlich alle geheult haben, dass ihre Server nicht mehr funktionieren und das Ganze hieß dann irgendwie Distributed Nile of Service, das heißt also verteilte Attacken auf Server oder Angriff auf Server, wo dann alle auch von Daten überflutig geworden sind.
Das war schon ein bisschen vorher. Aber was ganz interessant passiert ist, dass sich die Herangehensweise der Leute geändert hat. Früher war das so ein bisschen peinlich, wenn der Server gehackt wurde und wenn man nicht erreichbar war. Und heute kokettieren die Leute sogar ein bisschen damit, sie sagen, hey, wir sind so wichtig, dass wir sogar gehackt wurden. Genau, also eins der schönsten Beispiele dafür war Netcolone in meinen Augen. Denn die sind sehr obskur runtergefahren und haben erst erklärt, ihr Deil-Inrouter hätte ein Problem. Dann haben sie erklärt, ihr Hauptrouter würde gerade geupdatet und daher gibt es Probleme. Und dann haben sie erklärt, irgendwie die Leitung sei kaputt.
Das gab es wirklich innerhalb von zwei Wochen seitlich die Leitung.
Innerhalb von einem Tag sogar gab es die wildesten Aussagen, die sind dann auch auf dem eigenen Webserver gewesen und sind dann aber plötzlich wieder weg gewesen. Und dann hieß es am Ende halt, wir sind gehackt worden. Genau, ein böse Hacker hat uns die Bandbreite geklaut und dann haben sie irgendeine Arme Studenten verhaftet.
Aber wenn ihr ein bisschen aufmerksam die Nachrichten verfolgt habt, all das ist tatsächlich Neues. Also im Internet ist Chaos, okay, es funktioniert nicht, es war auch nie für die Weltwirtschaft gedacht. Was Neues ist, dass sich jetzt aufgrund solcher Vorfelder sogar das Innenministerium in Bewegung setzt.
Naja, und ein fast greiser Innenminister dazu.
Genau, weil die Aufgabe des Innenministeriums und des Innenministers ist ja den Anschein der öffentlichen Sicherheit aufrechtzuerhalten. Also es geht hier nicht um die tatsächliche Sicherheit, sondern es geht um das sogenannte subjektive Unsicherheitsgefühl des Bürgers, das man adressieren muss. Nun haben die aber auch schon gemerkt, dass es eben nicht damit getan ist, hier mehr Polizisten an den Datenautobahnen aufzustellen, weil dadurch wird das irgendwie auch nicht sicherer. Und immerhin hat das BSI jetzt da gestern so ein Katalog vorgestellt, was man nicht alles machen könnte. Und man muss sagen, wir sind ja verhältnismäßig angenehm überrascht.
Sie haben mich als erste Mal verleihen.
BSI Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik. Das ist sozusagen die Unterabteilung des Innenministeriums, was die Sicherheit von Computern betrifft. Es sind lauter, ganzige Herren um die 50, die sich in Kompetenzsimulationen, was das Internet betrifft, üben. Also wenn ich eine Frage zu CPM hätte oder so, dann würde ich die ganz bestimmt konsultieren. Aber das Internet betrifft ist halt auch für die noch relativ neu. Trotzdem haben sie verhältnismäßig sinnvolle Vorschläge herausgeschält und gestern vorgestellt und auch wenn die Zeitungen teilweise daraus die Überschrift gemacht haben, irgendwie Hacker mussten wir kämpfen. Muss man doch sagen, dass das was sie da technisch gesagt haben, nämlich man könnte zum Beispiel das Spoofing verhindern, relativ sinnvoll erstmal ist. Vielleicht mag Felix noch mal kurz ein Exkurs zu Spoofing gehen.
Ja, also das Hauptproblem bei den Distributed Digital Service Attacken ist, dass die Angriffe von vielen Rechnern kommen und dass die Absenderadressen falsch sind. Also man kann im Internet Pakete verschicken, wie im realen Leben und da schreibt man einen Empfänger drauf und man schreibt einen Absender drauf. Und den Absender, da kann man im Grunde eintragen, was man möchte, weil das von den Routern nicht weiter benutzt wird. Und wenn man da was anderes einträgt als den tatsächlich richtigen Absender, dann spricht man von einem Peace Spoofing. Und der Effekt ist, dass wenn man angegriffen wird, man zwar die Tatsache feststellen kann, dass man da geflutet wird, dass hier viel Traffic ist, aber man kann nicht feststellen, von wem das tatsächlich kommt.
Das ist ungefähr so, als wenn dir der Post bot und den ganzen Lastwagen voll Päckchen irgendwie hinweggelegt hat.
Die schönste Analogie, die ich gelesen habe, war dieser Kindergartenstreich, wenn man seinem wüssten Feind 100 Zeitungen Abonnements zukommen lässt. Und dann kriegt er halt mit der Post 100 Zeitungen und hat keine Ahnung von, wo das jetzt kommt.
Und es geht auch nichts mit seinen Briefkassen rein, das heißt, er kann aber auch nicht mal seine Rechnungen und Warnungen irgendwie kriegen.
Das ist doch, wie hat man Klopapier gefaxed in solchen Fällen auch, ne?
Oder das berühmte Endlos-Fax, wie das neungeklebte. Nein, nicht Klopapier, sondern du fax lauter schwarze Seiten auf Kermotapier-Faxgeräte. Weil dann fangen die Dinger nämlich eventuell an zu brennen. Das Ding heißt nämlich Kermofax, weil die schwarze Schrift dadurch entsteht, dass da was erhitzt wird, nämlich eine kleine Nadel. Und wenn die dauerhaft erhitzt wird, dann kann das...
Allerdings ist die Versicherung dann sogar irgendwann gefordert, dass nach sieben Minuten irgendwie muss der Fachzett einfach ausschalten. Die Feuerversicherung war dann teilweise noch nüchtern.
Aber was sie nicht alles gefordert haben und was nicht alles in Gesetzen steht.
Na gut, aber im Grunde, das Problem ist eben bei diesen DIN-HALF-SERVICE-Attakten, dass man selbst wenn es nur einer ist, der angreift, nicht sieht, von wo es jetzt genau kommt. Und das ist ein Problem, was nicht auf Seite des Angriffen behoben werden kann, schon prinzipiell nicht. Das heißt, die einzige Möglichkeit das zu beheben ist, wenn verhindert wird, dass ich mit meinem Server, der irgendwo steht, Pakete rausschicken kann, die sagen, sie kämen von woanders. Und das kann verhindert werden, und zwar von meinem Internetprovider. Und das ist eine der Forderungen, das ist ein Maßnahmenkatalog mit 15 Punkten, dieses BSI-Papier. Und das ist eine der Forderungen, die der Chaos Computer Club im Übrigen seit mehreren Jahren publiziert hat, aber die nie irgendwie weitergebracht wurden. Und deswegen freut uns das ganz enorm, dass das BSI das in diesem Fall auch schreibt, weil das ist die Wahrheit. Das ist tatsächlich die einzige Sache, die hilft gegen Distributed Internet of Service.
Wobei, man muss ja auch kurz zur Entstehungsgeschichte sagen, ich war zufällig vor 10 Tagen in dieser Passport-Internetsicherheit im Innenministerium in Bonn, wo dieser Maßnahmenkatalog vorgestellt wurde und die Vorstellungen, die da ursprünglich geäußert wurden, waren schon genau so abenteuerlich, wie man sich das vorstellt. Beispielsweise, ja, man könne ja den Internetzugriff für Normalbürger auf SMTP und HTTP begrenzen. Dann kamen auch so andere Sachen auch, wie ja, man müsste strategische Maßnahmen entwickeln um dieses und jenes. Und dann hat der Duby aus Köln, der war auch mit, der hat dann, genauso wie ich, irgendwann haben wir die Geduld verloren. Dann haben wir gesagt, also warum schreibt man nicht einfach, macht was gegen das Proofing? Und dann sagte der vom Innenministerium, der sprang dann auf und meinte, das ist jetzt aber viel zu konkret und technisch, er wollte doch hier goldene Regeln und strategische Maßnahmen. Und so weiter und so fort. Also die haben ja schon erstmal ihren Plan natürlich. Was bemerkenswert war, bei dieser sogenannten innerdeutschen Meinungsbildung, also es ging darum, zusammen mit Multimedia-Verbänden der Telekom und so weiter und so fort, eben erstmal die Lage zu sichten und sich zu überlegen, was könnte man Sinnvolles machen, war eine amerikanische Migration anwesend. Immerhin vier Leute, die sich in die Teilnehmerliste, teilweise mit State Department, teilweise mit ja, Embassy in Berlin, Embassy Bonn eingetragen haben, dann noch von der National Security Assurance Center-Angelegenheit, die halt dort irgendwie den Rederaum in der Hand von 20 Minuten bekommen haben, ihre Vorstellungen zu äußern, wo sie dann immer wieder auf sogenannte Public-Private Partnership, das ist so ein amerikanisches Dortmar irgendwie, keine Ahnung, und natürlich irgendwie das übliche, der Staat muss das Internet überwachen, damit es sicher ist, weil das ist ja jetzt Infrastruktur und die ganze Kinderphorografie. Aber immerhin, aber die haben dann wohl auch gemerkt, dass sie damit schwer anecken würden, und insofern ist das, was dabei rausgekommen ist, relativ tragbar.
Ja, du sagtest eben, Chefe, eine Frage hätte ich noch, dieser eine Punkt wäre zumindest was, was der CCT befürwortet, oder ist das bei den anderen Punkten auch richtig?
Ja, gut, aber da steht auf der einen Seite drin, wie setzt Open Source Technologie ein, weil sonst könnt ihr nicht überprüfen, ob es sicher ist, und vor allem könnt ihr nicht schnell reagieren, wenn auftaucht, dass es irgendwie ein Problem gibt. Auf der anderen Seite steht aber auch als einer der Regeln drin, besorgt euch die vom FBI herausgegebene Überprüfungstunst für eure Computer, und die liegen eben nicht im Source-Grip vor. Das heißt, da wird einem empfohlen, ein ausgerechnet von der amerikanischen Polizeibehörde ausgegebenes Programm, wo kein Mensch weiß, was da drin steht und was das macht, auf seinem Computer zu installieren. Geben Sie doch der nächsten Woche die Zeitwache an Wohnungsschlüsseln, natürlich werden wir uns anständig in Ihrer Wohnung benehmen.
Das ist ja noch weitergehend. Das Problem ist noch ein bisschen subtil, aber es ist ja weitgehend, denn das ist einfach ein normaler Webserver. Das heißt, man kann selbstverständlich auch als Angreifer IPs-Boofing benutzen, um Leuten, die da versuchen, das Tooldown zu moden, irgendein anderes Tool unterzujubeln. Das heißt, man weiß nicht mal, ob das tatsächlich vom FBI kommt. Also die eigentlichen Probleme sind da schon vielschichtig. Aber um noch eine Sache aus USA zu bringen, da gab es auch eine Presseerklärung vom State Department. Und die haben gesagt, ja, wir haben ja überlegt, ob wir jedem ISP einen Kontaktbereichsbeamten zuordnen. Also ist das nicht so, dass die Polizei da in ganz hergebrachten Linien denkt. Insofern ist das sehr erfreulich, dass das BSI da deutlich moderner vorgeht.
Das erinnert mich ja schwer an Datenblockwarte.
Ich habe ein leichtes technisches Problem. Ich würde die Herrschaften bitten weiter zu. Ich weiß nicht, Musik hat einfach aufgehört.
Ja, dann mach doch nochmal.
Ich weiß nicht, warum das jetzt einfach weg ist.
Ja, wir können uns da mal kurz sortieren, wenn wir an der Rheinmusik spielen. Bevor wir jetzt zum eigenen Thema der Sendung kommen, nämlich zu ja letztendlich Digitalisierung von Tönen und Bildern und den Möglichkeiten, das über das Netz quasi als Radio oder Fernsehsender zu Multicasten, wollen wir noch mal ganz kurz ein, zwei Termin an und Absagen machen.
Also wir haben ja ganz, ganz, ganz schlechte Nachrichten.
Genau, gegen anderslautenden Gerüchten müssen wir uns dieses Jahr erst mal erholen und machen kein Sommercamp. Also das liegt auch daran, dass unser Zeremonienmeister, der hat jetzt erst mal eine dreimonatige Welt vorgemacht, der ist noch gar nicht wieder da. Der gute Tim kommt irgendwann Ende Mai wieder. Und dann werden wir sehen, ob wir ihm zu irgendwas Magischem bewegen können.
Ich hab ein zweites Mal...
Ein zweites Mal fahren wir zumindest Mitte Juli nach New York. Da geben sich die Jungs von der 2600 die Hope2K, das ist die Hackers of Planet Earth im Hotel Pennsylvania. Vom 14. bis 16. Juli, wenn ich's richtig im Kopf hab, guckt mal h2k.net oder off oder irgendwas. Und dann gibt's Ende Juli die DevCon in Las Vegas. War da eigentlich schon mal jemand von euch?
Ja, Andreas war da schon mal. Also die DevCon ist beschreckt.
Also es ist die heißeste Jahreszeit da.
Ja, aber es ist ja witzig. Also da passieren so Sachen wie, dass die Displays in den Hotels gehackt werden, wo draus steht, wie viele Zimmer noch frei sind. Und da sind dann irgendwelche Lomos von Hackerparty. Das ist ganz witzig. Also das Problem ist natürlich, dass die ganze Hacker-Szene so tierisch im Aufblänen ist im Moment, weil alle möglichen Institutionen glauben, da irgendwelche abgesandten hinschicken zu müssen. Und daher gibt es also...
Das heißt es sind letztendlich mehr Schriftsträger als Hacker.
Genau, einfach mehr Schriftsträger. Naja, die versuchen sich dann so ein bisschen zu tarmen. Das heißt, inzwischen ist das so, dass da ganz viele Leute rumlaufen, die so...
Mit Linux-T-Shirts, ja?
Ja, so viel. Retail-T-Shirts, wir sind auch Elite, ja? Aber es gibt immer noch so, wenn man die Leute mal gesehen hat oder sich im Internet mal getroffen hat, dann kann man da schon Spaß haben. Deswegen hoffen wir da auf das Beste.
Tja, was haben wir noch an Terminen?
Ähm, Ausruhen.
Ausruhen, ja. Und diese Dinge. So, jetzt könnten wir eigentlich...
Aber jetzt noch irgendwie Radio-Themen anfangen. Nee, das ist...
Okay, fangen wir jemanden an.
Die beste Kleinigkeit hatten wir noch zusammen oder nicht? Bei den News?
Bei den News, naja, das war diese Sache mit den Abhörprotokollen der Stasi. Aber da wollten wir eigentlich auch erst ein bisschen später noch drüber reden, weil da haben wir vorhin schon gemerkt bei der Pizza auf dem Weg hierher, dass das doch ein ziemlich komplexes Thema ist.
Also, wir beglücken euch jetzt noch ein, zwei Minuten mit russischer Technolala, die wie gesagt leider nur in Kirillöschen identifiziert ist.
Aber vielleicht kommt hier noch ein Russe vorbei.
Aber ich weiß, dass ich es nicht weiß. Aber ich weiß, dass ich es nicht weiß. Aber ich weiß, dass ich es nicht weiß. Aber ich weiß, dass ich es nicht weiß. Aber ich weiß, dass ich es nicht weiß. Aber ich weiß, dass ich es nicht weiß. Ich sehe, diejenigen, die sich vielleicht fragen, wie wir dazu kommen, hier russischen Techno zu spielen. Also ich war gerade auf einer Cyber-Rides-Konferenz in Moskau. Da ging es darum, von der ACLU, von der American Civil Liberty Union, finanziert mit anderen Privacy-Verbänden, also mit den EPIC-Jungs und so russischen Bürgerrechtlern ein bisschen die Problemlage im Bezug auf Internet, Privatsphäre und ähnliches zu erklären. Die Lage in Russland ist die, es gibt zwar diese SORM-Initiative, also staatliche Überwachung aller Internet-Provider und mehr oder weniger auch aller Accounts, also die wollen gleich direkt Zugriff auf E-Mail und so weiter und so fort, aber das ist noch nicht realisiert und es gibt zwar eine Lizentierungspflicht für Krypto-Aufgeschichten, aber im Moment ist es einfach so, dass die Jungs von der Staatssimulation da, dass eigentlich auch nur die Mafia es halt noch andere Sorgen haben und das heißt, man hat dort noch einen relativen Freiraum im Internet im Bezug auf die Möglichkeit zu publizieren, im Gegensatz zum möglichen Leben, wo dann doch die Maschinengewehre und andere Strukturen einem relativ schnell beileiberücken. Und so hatte ich halt die Gelegenheit euch hier ein bisschen russischen Techno anzupassen.
Was kostet sowas in Russland?
Na ich habe 130 Rubel für die CD bezahlt, das sind so ungefähr acht Mark. Das ist aber wirklich jenseits von dem, was sich da normale Bürger leisten wollen. Also zum Vergleich, eine U-Bahnfahrt kostet etwa fünf, vier oder fünf Rubel, da sind so 40 fertig, unsere Mark sind 14 Rubel und naja, so das ist aber, ich habe keine Ahnung, was die Leute da verdienen. Es ist sehr unterschiedlich, man sieht so zwei Drittel echte Schrottautos herumfahren und das andere Drittel ist irgendwie die fette neue S-Klasse mit dunkel getönten Scheiden, die einfach quer über die roten Ampeln rüberfahren, kurz das Blaulicht anmachen, wieder ausmachen und die... Naja, das ist ja einfach so, du siehst da halt diese fetten S-Klassen, die haben so ihr Blaulicht drauf und wenn die irgendwie vor einer roten Ampel stehen, machen die das an, fahren rüber, machen es wieder aus. Und es gibt zwar Polizisten, aber die Polizisten verdienen oft mal sehr wenig Geld und die sind eigentlich den ganzen Tag damit beschäftigt, so normale Russen anzuhalten, denen zu sagen, sie haben jetzt irgendwie einen Verkehrsverstoß begangen und entweder können sie jetzt mit auf die Wache kommen und Bürokratie und so fort oder eben 100 Rubelbar auf die Hand oder so. Das heißt, du siehst ja die ganze Zeit wirklich, wie die Straßenräuber, die Polizisten die Autos anhalten und sich irgendwie da munter das Bargeld geben lassen.
Und der Bargain mit der S-Klasse rauscht über die Ampel.
Genau, und die Mafia hat halt da ihre eigenen Regeln, die werden von den Polizisten natürlich nicht angehalten, weil wenn die irgendwie angehalten werden, dann kurbeln die kurz die Scheibe runter, Maschinengewehr raus und es ist der Polizist in ihrem Graben. Es ist aber trotzdem, es klingt vielleicht dramatisch, was ich erzähle, aber es ist eine unheimlich entspannte Stand, weil es ist nicht so wie vor einigen Jahren, dass da noch die Gebietstreitigkeiten laufen, sondern die Gebiete sind einfach aufgeteilt, die Macht ja ist präsent, aber normalerweise hat man mit den Jungs keinen Ärger, weil die machen halt ihr Business.
Da rückt ja wahrscheinlich auch jetzt eine Generation nach, die das illegale Geld legalisiert.
Ach ja, ich hab da auch Märkte gesehen, wo es ohne Ende Raubdrucke von Videos und CDs gibt, die eben auch für diese Preise so 7-8 Mark umgerechnet, auch Videos so, und da denkst du natürlich schon, dass die weniger die Copyright-Kohle abgedrückt haben, aber auf der anderen Seite auch Nike-Schuhe, Christa, für 20 Mark, ist schon klar, das sind inländische Produkte, nur mit einem anderen Label, ist aber besser für die Ökonomie, als würden sie jetzt Amerika in Porto beziehen, ne?
Die Zwei-Lassung der in Malaysia entführten Touristen verlangen die Geiselnähme umgerechnet 1, 5 Millionen Mark Lösegeld. Wie es aus Regierungskreisen weiterhieß, wurden die 21 Geiseln auf einer Insel im Süden der Philippinen festgehalten. Sprechverkaufsbewegung das ein Teil der Sozialeinheiten der Armee seien bereits auf der Insel. Einigung, die Angehörigen der Opfer des Seilbahnunglücks von Kavalese erhalten Schadensersatz in Höhe von je 2 Millionen Dollar. Das teilte einer der Opferanwälte mit. Bei dem Unglück im Februar 98 hatte ein US-Militärjet das Kabel einer Seilbahn durchtrennt. 20 Skifahrer starben in der abstürzenden Gondel. Vorwurf, sieben US-Waffenhersteller und die Nationale Vereinigung für Skisport haben Klage gegen das Wohnungsbauministerium und verschiedene Politiker eingereicht. Sie werfen ihnen vor mit ihren Drängen auf verstärkte Sicherheitsdienste, die in der Verfassung verengelten, Garantien für freien Handel zu verletzen. Aufschub, der Flug der US-Raumfahrer Atlantis zur Baustelle der Internationalen Raumstation ist heute zum dritten Mal in Folge verschoben worden. Als Grund nannte die US-Raumfahrtbehörde NASA Regen und zu starke Winde auf den Notlandeplätzen in Marokko und Spanien. Im Mai soll ein neuer Startversuch unternommen werden.
Sport!
In einem Fußballländerspiel trennten sich am Abend in Kaiserslautern, Deutschland und die Schweiz 1 zu 1. Der deutsche Meister Alba Berlin unterlag im Playoff Viertelfinale der Basketball-Bundesliga der Männer bei Brandhagen überraschend mit 63. Das ist das, was wir sehen. Wir haben zurzeit keine aktuellen Meldungen. Gute Fahrt.
Ja, danke schön. Fritz Kroos informiert Gerald Kötterheim euch um 22.32 Uhr.
Dienstag, 2.
Mai.
In Kolumbia, Fritz.
Oh, hey, oh, hey, oh, hey, oh, hey.
Vielleicht sagt ihr besser, worum es geht. Genau, wir wollen euch ein bisschen erzählen, wie man ganz prima im Internetradio machen kann. Das heißt also nicht nur hören kann. Das heißt, ihr kennt ja wahrscheinlich die Leute, die viel im Netz unterwegs sind, kennen irgendwie, dass man Fritz auch über Re-Audio hören kann als Livestream sozusagen. Das heißt also, wenn ihr kein Radio gerade zur Verfügung habt oder irgendwie am anderen Ende der Welt sitzt und irgendwie aber gerade ein gutes Internet habt, dann könnt ihr Fritz da auch übers Netz hören. Und bevor man irgendwie so eine Sachen übers Internet schicken kann, müssen da auch die Daten komprimiert werden. Weil so eine CD, die hat irgendwie ganz wahnsinnig viel Daten, weil die in super guter Qualität ist. Und da haben sich so verschiedene Leute ausgedacht, wie man diese Daten so weit zusammenpacken kann, dass sie irgendwie einigermaßen vernünftig durch so ein Internet zu schicken sind, was ja auch nicht so super schnell ist, wie ihr wahrscheinlich auch wisst. Das berühmte Format dafür heißt MP3 oder eins der berühmten Formate heißt MP3, ist eine Kurzform für MPEG-1 Layer 3 und ist eigentlich ein sehr effektives Komprimierungsformat. Dann gibt es da noch ein paar andere, da werden wir später noch drauf eingehen. Ich denke mal, Felix erklärt jetzt mal ganz kurz, was es so mit MP3 auf sich hat.
Also grundsätzlich die Frage beim Komprimieren ist, gibt es traditionelle Verfahren, die versuchen, Sachen, die mehr als einmal vorkommen, nur einmal abzulegen und später dann zu sagen, wiederhol mal von Sekunde 5 bis Sekunde 13 oder so was, das funktioniert bei Audio leider überhaupt nicht. Also es funktioniert schon, aber nur, wenn die Musik computergeneriert ist und sehr einfache Mustern entspringt. Ansonsten könnte man sich noch überlegen, eine Kompression, die darauf basiert, dass der Computer erkennt, jetzt ist eine Tuba, die ein Rohs A spielt und legt dann sowas ab, das wäre sehr platzsparend. Aber es gibt noch keinen, der es geschafft hat, ein Computerprogramm zu schreiben, was aus einem Sound-Pfeil, aus einer Eingabe diese Rückanalyse macht. Daher, so weit sind wir noch nicht. Was man stattdessen macht, ist, dass man Untersuchungen durchgeführt hat an Personen, denen hat man einfach Sounds vorgespielt, verschiedene Samples, und hat dann geguckt, welche Teile hören die Leute und welche nicht. Das heißt, man hat über manche Stellen einfach Lautstärke rübergelegt, hat die leise gemacht, hat da Rauschen draufgetan und hat geguckt, ab wann die Leute gesagt haben, das stört uns, oder was stört uns mehr, an welchen Stellen stört uns das mehr, wo kann man mehr Rauschen verkraften. Und diese Analysen sind schon eine ganze Weile her, die sind ursprünglich gemacht worden, als die Frage war, wie man telefonieren macht, also welche Bereiche man für Telefon braucht in den 50er- 60er-Jahren. Und diese Analysen waren aber hinreichend genug, dass man heute die Musik nach Frequenzbändern unterteilen kann. Das heißt, was man tut, ist, dass man eine sogenannte Fourier-Transformation oder eine ähnliche Transformation macht und dann feststellt, in dem Bereich der menschlichen Stimme, also ich sag mal jetzt ein Bass, ganz grob, oder ein Bariton oder Tenor, das sind bestimmte Bereiche von Frequenzen. Und man stellt eben fest, welcher Bereich wichtig ist und welcher nicht für das Ohr. Und genau genommen gibt es da Maskierungseffekte, wenn zum Beispiel man eine Zugaufnahme hat, und man hört ein Zug vorbeifahren und daneben sitzt einer und spielt Mutharmonika, dann hört man die Mutharmonika nicht während der Zug vorbeifährt, obwohl das Geräusch nach wie vor da ist. Das heißt, der Ansatz bei Audiokompression heute ist, dass man diese Situationen versucht, mit einem Computerprogramm zu erkennen und dann die Mutharmonika einfach nicht mitspeichert. Nicht mal grob zu sagen. Also das ist jetzt nicht, Mutharmonika ist jetzt nicht das Instrument, sondern der Frequenzbereich ist einfach weniger wichtig an der Stelle. Und so funktioniert im Grunde Audiokompression, dass man die Bereiche, von denen man weiß, dass sie für das Ohr, für das Gesamtklangbild nicht wichtig sind, einfach nicht mitschickt.
Und nach Ampere 3 gibt es ja noch das nächstbekanntere, würde ich mal sagen, es ist Real Audio Format. Da sendet, glaube ich, oder sendet in Anführungszeichen, verschickt ja auch Fritz seine Streams mit, wenn ich das richtig finde.
Broadcasting, das glaube ich dann so bei uns.
Es ist leider nicht Broadcast, sondern Indiecast.
Daneben gibt es ja noch Liquid Audio. Das hat sich ein bisschen, nein, nicht wirklich durchgesetzt, aber es wird gerne für Audio-on-Demand-Geschichten. Das heißt also, wenn ich mir eine CD aus dem Internet kaufen möchte, sozusagen, oder einen Song kaufen möchte, gibt es diese Music-on-Demand-Geschichten von der Telekom, glaube ich.
Na ja, eigentlich ist Liquid Audio tot, können wir mal konstatieren, benutzt im Grunde niemanden privat.
Ja, es ist also einfach nicht mehr so wahnsinnig wichtig. Vor allem, weil es eben auch diesen Kopierschutz und diesen Bezahlgedanken hat. Deswegen, würde ich mal sagen, hat sich das auch nicht so wahnsinnig durchgesetzt. Daneben gibt es dann noch QuickTime Audio und von Microsoft das Advanced Streaming-Format ASF. Und ein ganz neuer Kandidat macht jetzt ein bisschen von sich reden, da hat, glaube ich, auch der Spiegel online gerade was zu gepostet noch, nennt sich AAC. Und es wird als der offizielle Nachfolger von MP3 gehandelt.
Also was der Witz daran ist, so für das Verständnis, dass die Verfahren zwar alle anders heißen, aber im Grunde genau das Gleiche tun. Also es gibt zwar andere Ansätze, um Audiokompressionen zu machen, die darauf basieren, die Stimme zu modellieren. Das wird gemacht, wenn man ganz wenig Bandbreite hat, so für Funkverbindungen auf See oder so. Also wenn man wirklich fast gar keine Bandbreite hat und es nicht wichtig ist, ob da Musik drüber kommt, sondern nur die Stimme. Dann gibt es andere Ansätze, aber für die allgemeine Soundkompression gibt es eigentlich nur diesen einen Ansatz. Und es sind auch nur zwei, drei Papers, die überhaupt jemals gemacht wurden, weil diese Hörtests sehr teuer sind. Das heißt, alle Verfahren, ob nun MP3, AAC, Quicktime oder was auch immer, basieren alle auf den gleichen Papers und den gleichen Ideen. Das heißt, die Verfahren sind im Grunde auch gleich. Das Einzige, was MP3 auszeichnet, ist, dass definiert ist, wie das abgespeichert ist. Und diese Definition ist offen zugänglich. Und das ist auch der Grund, warum MP3 so erfolgreich ist, weil im Grunde jeder, der genügend Zeit hat und genügend also Bezahlungen sichern kann, um da ein paar Monate dran zu arbeiten, dass der einen Grund einen MP3-Player und auch einen MP3-Encoder schreiben könnte. Und tatsächlich hat gerade jemand, basierend auf den gleichen Papern, einen völlig freien Codec geschrieben, der heißt Ogg Vorbis. Der ist auch gerade ein bisschen durch die News gegangen. So ganz wenige Leute wissen davon, das war auf Heisekurz. Aber es ist tatsächlich möglich, dass ein einzelner, sehr interessierter, so eine Audiokompression tatsächlich mal selber schreibt.
Wobei, das ist aber eine Firma eigentlich, der das hinterstellt.
Nein, das ist ein einzelner, das ist auch der Mann, der... Das ist ein einzelner Typ eigentlich. Der hat da seine One-Man-Show gemacht. Und das ist tatsächlich GPL. Das heißt, die Software ist frei und auch nicht patentbelastet. Also es ist möglich. Und das ist auch das, was MP3 tatsächlich so erfolgreich gemacht hat. MP3 hat nämlich auch, das wissen die wenigsten, die ein paar Jahre vor sich hin existiert, ohne dass es irgendjemand benutzt hätte. Und es ist in dem Moment erfolgreich geworden, wo es einen freien Player gab und wo in der Raubkopierszene einen Inkoder verfügbar war. Denn die Leute benutzen Musik nicht, um irgendwie den CD-Kauf zu ändern. Die Leute kaufen nach wie vor CDs, kaufen sogar mehr CDs als letztes Jahr. Aber Leute benutzen Audiokompressionen, um privat ihre CDs auf Platte zu samplen und das vielleicht ihrem Freund zu geben. Und deswegen sind diese ganzen Kopierschutzgedanken, die heutzutage immer wieder gerne erwähnt werden, bei Audiokompressionen, sind im Grunde eine Sache, die nicht nur nicht gebraucht wird, sondern die auch ihrem Weg steht und aber auch kein glückliches Problem ist. Kommen wir später dazu.
Na ja, du solltest vielleicht schon nochmal kurz was dazu sagen. Dieses Advanced Audio Coding AAC wird ja gerade damit promotet.
Na ja, der Spiel hat das so kreditsimiert.
Ja, naja, gut, okay. Aber es ist ja nun so schon, das zumindest weiß ich auch vom Fraunhofer Institut, dass die mit MP30 nun nicht nur Freunde gemacht haben, weil inwieweit da jetzt tatsächlich wirtschaftlicher Schaden entstanden ist, sei mal dahingestellt, aber zumindest hat es die Musikindustrie halt nicht gerne, wenn irgendwie auf einmal sich jeder alles frei besorgen kann, weil man will ja die Kontrolle haben. Also vielleicht ist es sogar eher was Psychologisches, als was tatsächlich Monetär ist.
Genau, das ist also oft genug was Psychologisches, weil der CD-Absatz muss zwangsläufig zurückgehen, weil alle die Leute haben, das war bei Einführung der CD, haben sich alle Leute in Westdeutschland erstmal den gesamten Backkatalog, den sie zu Hause haben, also alle Platten nochmal neu auf CD gekauft, und das ist jetzt im Osten passiert, und das schlaut jetzt auch ab. Und darum ist da ein Gewinneinbruch. Also ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass es auch so was zurückführbar ist.
Ist aber nicht wirklich messbar. Es ist sogar so, dass die Plattenindustrie mehr umgesetzt hat als letztes Jahr. Das ist kontinuierlich.
Es ist nicht so viel, wie sie gehofft hatten, aber es ist da messbar, dass die Leute eh tendenziell weniger Kohle haben.
Es ist da messbar, wo das kleine Label oder der kleine Agent, der ein paar Künstler an der Vertrag hat, irgendwie spürbar was hat. Aber vielleicht hätte der seinen Laden gar nicht erst aufgemacht, wenn das alles nicht gewesen wäre. Das ist auch die Frage.
Inwieweit ist denn da bei AAC eine Form von Watermarking schon realisiert? Hast du dir das mal angeguckt?
AAC ist von den gleichen Leuten gemacht worden, die vorher MP3 gemacht haben. Die haben auch für MP3 ein Watermarking-Standard definiert. Den haben sie auch versucht zu positionieren. Der ist im Grunde total eingegangen. Der Grundsatzgedanke bei Watermarking ist, dass ein Kopierschutz grundsätzlich nicht möglich ist. Weil ich kann mir das auf meiner Stereo-Anlage anhören und kann das dann analog mit dem Mikrofon, im schlimmsten Fall, wenn der Weg völlig zugekleistert ist, kann ich das mit dem Mikrofon gleich wieder vom Lautsprecher abnehmen und natürlich wieder aufnehmen. Das heißt, das Kopieren kann grundsätzlich nicht verhindert werden, sobald ich mir das anhören kann. Deswegen sind die Kopierschutzgedanken heutzutage so weit, dass man nicht das Kopieren verhindert, sondern es im Nachhinein erkennen will. Das bedeutet also, dass man nicht nur die Musik verkauft, sondern da einen Watermark drauf macht.
Zum Beispiel die Kreditkartennummer, das ist derjenige, der das gekauft hat. Wenn ich weiß, ich hab jetzt eine CD bestellt, gekauft, und ich weiß, wenn ich die jetzt an 1000 Leute weitergebe, oder mit Napstaff oder irgendwelche Server zugänglich mache, dann ist meine Kreditkartennummer überall. Das wäre eine Sache, die ich nicht toll finde.
Ist das ein Plan?
Ist das ein Problem? Ja, das ist möglich, aber...
Die stellen sich das so vor, dass sie dieses ARC mit entsprechenden Watermarking-Technologien als Nachfolger von MP3 positionieren und so einen fließen Übergang machen, weil es von der Qualität hier ein bisschen besser ist. Und weil man die Leute natürlich mit dem Qualitätsargument ködern kann und ihnen dann nebenbei eben die Watermarking und nebenbei noch die halbe Inhaftierung verpassen kann.
Das Qualitätsargument gab es bei Betamax auch schon mal.
Das Qualitätsargument ist ja auch nicht wirklich, sondern Qualität ist ja eine Frage der bittere Art. Das heißt, bei ARC ist es nur so, dass die Daten, die letztendlich rauskommen, bei gleicher Qualität im Vergleich zu MP3, ein bisschen kleiner sind.
Genau, also das Qualitätsargument ist sowieso entkräftet worden, seit die CT dann einen Hörtest gemacht hat von ein paar Ausgaben. Was die nämlich gemacht haben, ist, dass sie da einfach Leuten in einem Blindtest einmal MP3 mit 128 Kilo...
Also wohlgemerkt, nicht einfach Leute, sondern Leute, die sich auch für 20.000 Mark eine Stereoanlage hinschalten.
Genau, also auch die Utilen explizit, aber sie haben auch Leute von der Straße genommen und haben denen einfach einmal MP3 mit 128 Kb, das ist eher klein, niedrige Bitrate, und einmal mit 256 Kb, das ist eher höher, als man normalerweise benutzt, und einmal AudioCD, die Standardaufnahme vorgespielt hat. Und hat die dann gebeten, das zu identifizieren, was sie da gerade hören. Und es hat sich halt rausgestellt, dass die wenigsten das überhaupt konnten, also im Grunde keiner. Und am Ende gab es dann so viele böse Zuschriften, dass sie den Test noch mal gemacht haben, mit denen die da am lautesten krakielt haben und auch die haben es nicht wirklich auseinanderhalten können. Bis auf einen, der hatte einen Hörschaden.
Also MP3 basiert ja darauf, naja, das muss man ein bisschen auswählen.
MP3 basiert ja darauf, dass man Maskierungseffekte ausnutzt. Das heißt, wenn ich ein lautes Geräusch in den hohen, in den höheren Bereichen habe, und dann leises Geräusch in den kleineren Bereichen, das sende ich dann nicht mit. Und wenn ich jetzt einen Hörschaden habe, sodass ich die Höheren gar nicht höre, dann tritt diese Maskierung nicht auf. Das heißt, der hat es gehört, aber die anderen nicht. Das heißt, im Grunde kann man schon jetzt sagen, dass MP3 die Qualitätsansprüche voll erfüllt, die da gestellt werden für den Mann auf der Straße. Keine Frage. Und auch für die Audiophilen, die sich da wie für 30.000 Mark eine Stellanlage kaufen. Qualität ist nicht das Argument.
Aber hast du schon mal so einen Audiophilen wirklich getroffen?
Die schwören auch, dass sie auf Vinylplatten noch besseren Sound haben.
Ich meine, da wird jetzt Meta-Lautsprecherkabel für 80 Mark gekauft.
Da gibt es wirklich kranke Sachen.
Ein Typ, der schwor, dass die CDs besser klingen, wenn er sie im Gefrierfach lagert.
Ja, das waren die 20er.
Aber so eine Leute gibt es und die haben sie auch nicht auseinanderhalten können. Qualität ist nicht das Argument. Was für AAC spricht, ist, dass es technische Gründe gibt, warum das besser ist und dass die Dateien kleiner werden. Aber AAC setzt sich genau wie MP3 erst dann durch, wenn es einen freien Player und einen freien Encoder gibt. Und im Moment gibt es zwar so Versuche, einen Player zu machen, die sind aber Schweine langsam, das heißt, die lassen einfach an heutigen Rechner einmal voll aus. Und Encoder, die in Echtzeit encoden, gibt es schon mal überhaupt nicht. Und frei erst recht nicht. Das heißt, im Moment ist AAC überhaupt nicht zu sehen. Und jetzt die Frage ist natürlich, kann AAC den Kopierschutz durchdrücken oder nicht? Und das kann man schon mal mit Nein beantworten, weil grundsätzlich der Mensch zu Hause, der AAC benutzt, die meisten im Moment im Internet getradeten mp3-Dateien sind keine Dateien, die ich bei mp3.com gekauft habe, sondern ist halt irgendjemand von seiner CD gesampelt. Das heißt, wenn es einen freien Encoder gibt und irgendjemand von seiner CD die Sachen sampelt und ins Netz tut, dann macht er das natürlich ohne Kopierschutz. Er will sie ja kopieren. Und deswegen, wenn das Format einen Kopierschutz hat, den ich auch ausstellen kann, was natürlich so sein wird, bringt ja keinen Sinn sonst, weil es gibt auch einfach nicht kopiergeschützte Sounds. Also es muss das Format auch ohne Kopierschutz geben, dann werden die Leute das ohne Kopierschutz benutzen, damit ist die ganze Diskussion einfach hinfällig. Ja, in dem Moment. Das war's für heute. Wir werden dir gebacken! Also Watermarking, wie vorhin kurz angedeutet, heißt, dass man mehr Informationen als die Musik an den Kunden drückt und der Kunde möglichst keine Möglichkeit in die Hand gegeben bekommt, die reine Musik zu extrahieren. Und Kreditkarten, Nummer ist so ein Beispiel. Und jetzt fragt man sich, wie geht das? Möglichkeit eins wäre, dass man in dem Musikformat Datenfelder vorsieht, wo man irgendwie was eintragen kann. Nur dann ist es sehr einfach, ein Programm zu schreiben, wenn das Format publiziert ist, was diese Felder einfach rausschmeißt. Deswegen sind die Verfahren für Watermarking so, dass man es in der Musik kodiert. Das heißt, man benutzt genau die gleichen Papers, die sagen, welche Bereiche nicht so wichtig sind, nur dass man da eben dann die Daten unterbringt und nicht die wegkomprimiert. Das heißt, letztendlich, wenn man eine richtig gute Audiokompression hat, die würde dann das Watermarking gleich mit entfernen, weil es nämlich in den Bereichen ist...
Grit und Land.
Genau, ja, das Problem heißt aber, dass Watermarking deswegen nur funktionieren kann, wenn der Mann, der Watermarking implementiert hat, mehr Psychoakustikwissen hat, als der, der Kompression entwickelt hat. Und in Kompression ist gerade...
Das hab ich nicht verstanden.
Nein, der Punkt ist einfach, dass beide wissen müssen, welche Bereiche unwichtig sind. Der Watermarking-Mensch, um seine Sachen unterzubringen und der andere, um es wegzukomprimieren. Und wenn jetzt der Watermarking-Typ das unter so unterbringen will, dass der Komprimierer das nicht wegschmeißt, dann muss er mehr über Psychoakustik wissen als der Komprimierer. Mit Kompression kann man aber mehr Geld machen als mit Watermarking. Deswegen ist Watermarking immer schlechter und im Grunde einfach theoretisch nicht möglich, das vernünftig zu machen. Obwohl es da Ansätze gibt, sind die im Moment alle gescheitert.
Für Bäder gibt es sowas auch.
Für Bäder gibt es sowas auch, genau.
Schichten Digimark, glaube ich, heißen die das dann durch. Das ist aus dem Watermarking.
Also das kann man aber alles rein theoretisch knicken, einfach kann man vergessen.
So, und nachdem wir jetzt auch wieder zwei funktionierende Studio- und Multilautsprecher haben, geht's jetzt auch weiter. Wir wollen nämlich noch ein bisschen was erzählen, wie denn die Musik überhaupt in den Computer reinkommt. Also wir haben jetzt schon grad was über psychoakustische Modelle und Kompressionsverfahren gehört. Und dazu gibt's natürlich dann auch Software, die ihr braucht, um die ganzen Sachen dann von der CD oder vom Mikrofoneingang von eurer Soundcard auf den Rechner zu kriegen. Und so, wohl das bekannteste Programm oder die bekannteste Software dafür ist der Fraunhofer-Encoder nach MP3. Es gibt also eine ganze Menge Programme, die auf diesem Algorithmus, auf diesem Verfahren von Fraunhofer irgendwie aufsetzen. Viele Leute haben dann einfach nur so eine schicke Benutzeroberfläche dafür geschrieben und drunter ist dann letztendlich auch wieder dieser Fraunhofer-Encoder. Darüber hinaus gibt's dann noch irgendwie von der Firma Xing ein Encoder für MP3, der ist auch recht bekannt, recht fix, hat ab und zu mal ein bisschen den schlechten Ruf, dass die Qualität nicht so doll ist. Dann haben die dann so was gemacht, noch eine neue Version, ein paar Filter weggenommen und eingebaut wieder und so. Und jetzt ist es eigentlich so ganz brauchbar, denke ich mal, wenn man jetzt in aktuellen Berichten und Gerüchten trauen darf. Vor allem für die Linux-Leute ist noch was Interessantes, da gibt es nämlich den Lame, der irgendwie auch ganz fix ist.
Schöner Name.
Ja, Lame, klingt zwar Lame, aber ist eigentlich fix. Obwohl es gibt eine Assembler-handgetunete Rennversion von Lame, die heißt Gogo, das haben ein paar Japaner gemacht, und die benutze ich hier gerade, um ein paar CDs zu samplen. Ja, also Gogo ist im Grunde auch Lame, ist nur ein bisschen optimierte Routine.
Also Gogo ist wie Lame.
Ja, Gogo ist Lame mit ein bisschen handgetunten Kernroutinen. Ansonsten Lame ist eigentlich für alle gut. Lame kann man nur weiter empfehlen, also ich benutze Lame.
Darüber gibt es dann hinaus noch den QuickTime-Encoder, das heißt so, das ist für diese Sachen von Apple, was die entwickelt haben. Dann natürlich auch diesen, ich glaube, Real-Encoder, heißt er sogar richtig, Real-Encoder für die Real-Audio, bzw. Real-Video-Sachen. Und Microsoft ist natürlich auch mit dabei, mit ihrem Windows-Media-Encoder, wie auch immer.
Ja, Windows-Media-Framework. Also QuickTime ist auch nur ein Framework. Das ist da so, dass Microsoft eigentlich natürlich, also im Grunde kann sich keine Institution leisten, Hörtests zu machen, weil das Jahre dauert, also Jahre im Sinne von fünf bis zehn, bis man da anständige Daten gesammelt hat und bis man so einen Codec selber geschrieben hat, das kann man echt vergessen. Deswegen machen die Firmen das auch nicht, sondern kaufen das von anderen Firmen, die ihr Wissen aus dem MPEG-Konsortium ziehen. Das heißt, letztendlich sind es alles die gleichen Daten. Aber QuickTime heißt nur das Framework. Die Codex hat Apple auch nur dazu gekauft. Und so der bekannteste Codec bei QuickTime ist der Syrenson-Codec, der Video macht. Aber die Audio-Codecs sind auch nicht von Apple.
Genau, und wenn ihr dann die Sachen digital vorliegen habt, beziehungsweise von eurem Mischpool, mit dem ihr auf Sendung geht, in die Soundkarte reinschickt, dann braucht ihr auch einen Server, um das Ganze ins Netz zu streamen. Und ein recht berühmter und auch frei verfügbarer ist der Icecast-Server. Das ist auch eine Software, die einfach einen mp3-Stream sozusagen für mehrere Leute abruft. Kann man sich das, naja, nicht wie ein Chat-Server, aber so, wo einfach auch ganz viele Leute sich hin verbinden können und an diesem Stream anhören. Darüber hinaus gibt es dann auch noch den Shoutcast-Server. Das ist eine Entwicklung von Mollsoft. Das sind die Leute, die den legendären Windamp geschrieben haben. Jetzt aber, glaube ich, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, von AOL aufgekauft worden sind. Das ist natürlich irgendwie ganz dramatisch. Und eine Software, ein Tool mit einem komischen Namen, OPC-QM, genau, auch noch ganz sinnvoll. Und darüber hinaus gibt es dann auch noch das Internetradio Toolkit.
Gehen wir gleich noch ein bisschen rein.
Dann haben wir auch noch den Rui-Audio-Server, QuickTime und Microsoft wieder dabei.
Zu den Details kommen wir dann gleich noch nach dem Chaosradio News.
Mehr Kameras. Die Wagen der Berliner S-Bahn sollen mit Überwachungskameras ausgestattet werden. Testweise sind bereits zwei Züge damit unterwegs. Die lückenlose Überwachung erfolgt durch drei Kameras pro Wagen. In Hamburg läuft ein Ähnlichartest seit längerer Zeit, der aber bisher eher bescheidene Erfolge vorzuweisen hatte. Zwei Graffiti-Sprayer wurden identifiziert. Die WVG hat auf die U-Bahn und Busse eine Überwachung angekündigt. Leider bekommt der letzte Fahrgast kein Preisgeld in Höhe von 250.000 Mark. Das DDR-Ministerium für Stadt-Sicherheit hat über viele Jahre hinweg den Funkverkehr der Sicherungs- und Observationskräfte des Bundesnachrichtendienstes BND problemlos abhören können. Wie die Welt am Sonntag berichtet, sei der BND-Funkverkehr zwar durch Geräte der Marke VeryCrypt 1100 verschleiert worden. Der Stasi-Hauptabteilung 3 sei es aber gelungen, diesen in verständlicher Form abhörbar zu machen. Durch die Abhörmaßnahmen sei die Stasi in den Besitz unzähliger Informationen gelangt, die zur Enttarnung zahlreicher BND-Spione geführt hätten. Die Stasi-Lauscher hätten 80.000 Telefonanschlüsse in der Bundesrepublik permanent abgehört. Erst im September 1990 seien die Abhöraktivitäten eingestellt worden. Bundestag verabschiedet Fernabsatzgesetz. Der Bundestag hat ein neues Fernabsatzgesetz verabschiedet, das den Einkauf per Fernkommunikation regeln soll. Es erlaubt unter anderem, im Internet gekaufte Waren 14 Tage lang auf Kosten des Anbieters zurückzusenden. Ohne Bestellung gelieferte Waren müssen wieder zurückgeschickt, weder zurückgeschickt noch aufbewahrt werden. Anbieter müssen außerdem über ihre Identität, ihre Leistung und Lieferbedingungen umfassend informieren. Wenn Dritte die Daten von Geldkarten missbrauchen, sollen zukünftig die Banken haften. Der neue Verbraucherschutz erstreckt sich auch auf Katalog-Einkauf über Telefon, Fax oder Brief.
Der Chaosradio ticker mit Gerald Kötter ein.
Das Thema war eigentlich, wie kommen dann die Bits, die man jetzt sozusagen zu Hause produziert, weil nichts anderes ist ja Radio und Fernsehen, wie kommen die denn zu N-Empfängern? Nicht einem, sondern N. Und da gibt es im Groben zwei Methoden. Die eine ist...
Na drei. Das übliche ist eigentlich, dass ihr euch mit eurem Player irgendwie, MP3-Player oder Real-Audio, wie auch immer, Player, eine Verbindung zu dem Server aufbaut. Das heißt, da wird also ein Kanal eröffnet, der von euch zu dem Server geht, und ihr zieht euch gewissermaßen die Sachen von diesem Server dann da runter. Das heißt, die werden auf diesem Kanal dann zu euch geschickt. Wie ziehe ich mir die runter? Na ja, jedenfalls ist dafür ein extra Kanal notwendig. Das müsst ihr euch ungefähr so vorstellen, wenn ihr Radio hören wollt, müsst ihr alle mit dem Telefon beim Radiosender anrufen. Das heißt, ihr wählt euch da irgendwie ein, wir haben dann eine Telefonanlage, da gibt es vielleicht 100 Leitungen zu. Und ihr wählt euch da alle ein, um dann das Radio anzuhören. Aber da das natürlich Quatsch ist, gibt es irgendwie einfach Radio, so wie ihr es kennt, das heißt über Funkwann wird es ausgebreitet und jeder, der da irgendwie im Empfangsbereich ist, kann das empfangen. Und so eine ähnliche Idee gibt es für das Internet nämlich auch, und das heißt Multicast.
Ja, und dieses Problem, dass das einfach Quatsch ist, was wir jetzt hier so gesagt haben, das gibt es auch im pseudowissenschaftlichen Ausdruck für, nämlich Skalierbarkeit. Informatiker nennen Probleme ein Skalierbarkeitsproblem, wenn Sachen langsamer oder schlechter gehen, sobald mehr Leute teilnehmen oder solange mehr Daten beteiligt sind. Also grundsätzlich Skalierbarkeit ist auch bei Multicast das Problem. Multicast ist einfach eine Kommunikation, nicht mit einem Ziel, sondern mit mehreren Zielen. Das heißt, ich sende Daten einmal aus, sonst würde sich das ja nicht unterscheiden, und es können innen Leute hören.
Wobei, das ist also auch unbestimmtes, wer dazuhört. Das ist genauso wie bei Fritz. Wir wissen erstmal im Prinzip auch nicht, ob ihr jetzt irgendwie alle mit Radios da außen rumlauft oder irgendwie auch die Radios ausgeschaltet habt oder so.
Das Witzige ist, dass die ganzen... Also es ist verfahrensinherent, dass man nicht weiß, wer zuhört. Das muss einfach folgern aus den Voraussetzungen, die man bei Multicast hat. Es ist nicht so, dass man Multicast so machen könnte, dass man es schon weiß. Weil bei Multicast eine der Ideen war, dass ich mit meiner Modemleitung, die ich normalerweise zum Surfen benutze, auch ein Radio machen kann. Denn eigentlich reicht es, wenn ich die Bandbreite im Moment benutze, um Radio zu hören, dann reicht es natürlich auch, da einmal das rauszuschicken. Das heißt, wenn ich mit Multicast das so hinkriege, dass der Radiosender das, egal wie viele Leute zuhören, trotzdem nur einmal rausschickt, dann hat man das Ziel erreicht. Und deswegen ist gleichzeitig möglich, dass man mit der gleichen Bandbreite, die wir heute mit unseren Schmalspurmodems haben und benutzen, um damit Radio zu hören, auch einen Sender machen kann. Und deswegen, das ist so, was wir an Multicast auch förderungswillig, förderungsdünstig finden. Nämlich, dass in Zukunft es möglich sein wird, dass jeder Mann auf der Straße, jeder kleine Hacker, jeder kleine Computerbesitzer, der einen Internet-Deil ab hat, auch Radio machen kann.
Jetzt gibt es aber noch einen klitzekleinen Haken, nämlich, dass das im Moment noch nicht geht.
Genau. Das Problem ist, die Idee ist nicht ganz neu, sondern die kommt aus den 80er Jahren. Die ist tatsächlich ungefähr so alt wie das Web. Nur, dass das Web sich seitdem explosionsartig vermehrt hat, weil es von Anfang an funktioniert hat. Und bei Multicast hat es eben nicht von Anfang an funktioniert, sondern da war nur die Idee nett. Und seitdem haben sich da schlaue Köpfe das angeguckt und gesagt, hey, das ist toll, das wollen wir. Aber so richtig zu laufen gekriegt, haben wir das eigentlich bis heute nicht. Und das Hauptproblem ist das Routing an der Stelle. Routing ist normalerweise im Internet das Verfahren, mit dem die Rechner zwischen mir und meinem Zielrechner entscheiden, wie sie die Pakete weiter schicken. Im Grunde hat man sich das Netz vorzustellen wie so ein Netz. Also wie ein physikalisches Netz, das ist mit lauter Knoten in der Mitte und ich tu mein Paket bei mir rein. Und das Netz kennt dann immer den richtigen Weg und gibt es an den nächsten Knoten weiter, sodass es am Ende des Ziels erreicht. Und das Verfahren ist, wenn man nur immer nach dem Ziel geht, ganz einfach. Aber wenn man Multicast macht, geht man konzeptionell nicht nach dem Ziel, sondern man routet nach dem Sender. Weil das Ziel ist ja unbekannt. Es können Endziele sein, es können ganz viele sein, ganz wenige. Es kann auch gar keiner zuhören. Das heißt, das eigentliche Problem ist, woher weiß denn der Rechner, der kleint, also meine Oma möchte jetzt zuhören, meine Ausstrahlung, woher weiß denn der Rechner meiner Oma, dass ich das ausstrahle. Denn eine Sache, die man von vornherein als Forderung erstellt hat an Multicast, ist, dass man nicht eingibt, von wo die Sache kommen muss. Denn das wäre ja konzeptionell so, als wenn ich den Sendemast anrufe. Also wenn ich jetzt ARD gucken will, dass ich dann den Sendemast auswähle. Das muss man ja auch nicht machen heutzutage, sondern man gibt halt die Frequenz ein, und die ist hoffentlich im Kabelnetz gleich. Gut, so ist es auch nicht, aber im Grunde möchte man haben, dass man bei seinem Fernseher ARD eingibt und dann ist gut. Und man möchte dann nicht den Sendemast finden oder auswählen kann, sondern dass er automatisch laufen. Und diese Forderung macht Multicast sehr schwierig in der Umsetzung. Und tatsächlich die größten Probleme, die auftreten, sind gerade bei Routing.
So ich wollte jetzt noch mal den skeptischen Bürger spielen. Nämlich ja, das ist alles toll, was du erzählst, Felix. Und dass Multicast theoretisch die Möglichkeit bietet, von N-Sendern sozusagen an X oder N-Empfänger zu gehen. Das ist ja schön und gut. Aber wenn ich jetzt heute meinen Internetanschluss mir angucke, an welchem Provider ich auch immer hänge, dann geht das einfach nicht. Und das liegt daran, dass die Provider das noch nicht, ich sag jetzt mal implementiert haben. Oder eigentlich müsste man wahrscheinlich proakt sagen, sie haben es noch nicht aktiviert, weil ihre Router würden, ist ja erlauben, aber warum tun sie es eigentlich nicht?
Also es ist sogar so, dass viele Provider Multicast schon haben, aber das Hauptproblem ist zwischen den Providern.
Sie wissen auch nichts davon, oder?
Nee, zwischen den Providern. Also auch der Provider, wo ich privat meinen Internet abmache, hat eigentlich Multicast. Aber das Problem ist eben, das ist nur internes Multicast. Das heißt, wenn es da eine Ausstrahlung gibt, dann können das zwar alle Leute sehen, die bei diesem Provider auch sind.
Das hat so einen reichweiten Punkt.
Es ist nicht weltweit, naja, es ist auch nicht reichweite. Also es gibt Provider, die weltweit aktiv sind, wie Jujunet zum Beispiel. Die machen dann auch weltweit Multicast.
Also netzmäßig gesehen reichweite.
Es ist einfach so, dass die Provider sich da nicht absprechen. Und das ist gar nicht böser Wille, sondern von den Providern, sondern es gab da Versuche. Und wie das so ist, Provider möchten gern Geld verdienen und möchten dann guten Kunden, die gut zahlen, auch guten Service leisten. Und eine Sache, die bei Multicast Routing sich durchgesetzt hat, ist, dass man einen sogenannten Rendezvous-Point hat. Das heißt, einen Router, der für eine Multicast Group zuständig ist, für eine Ausstrahlung. Das heißt, man weiß, wenn man diese und jene IP für Multicast haben will, dann wendet man sich am Router XY und der steht jetzt bei einem anderen Provider als bei meinem eigenen. Das ist das Problem, was aufgetreten ist. Also nehmen wir mal an, ich bin jetzt bei, was weiß ich, Eht Online und die Multicast-Konferenz kommt aus Brasilien und der Rendezvous-Point steht in den USA. Und jetzt gibt es ein technisches Problem bei diesem Rendezvous-Point. Und wer soll da jetzt anrufen und sagen, es gibt ein Problem? Denn wenn ich da anrufe, dann hat der Provider keinen Grund, das zu beheben, weil ich ein T-Online-User bin. Ich zahle ihm ja kein Geld dafür. Also das eigentliche Problem ist ein billiges Problem. Und der Typ in Argentinien, der das ausstrahlt, der ist auch kein Kunde bei deinem Provider, wo der Rendezvous-Point steht. Also das ist die Art von Problem, die es heute gibt. Und es geht ja nicht nur darum zu sagen, wer ist jetzt zuständig, sondern auch, wie finde ich überhaupt raus, wer schuld ist. Denn bei Multicast sind ganz andere Routing-Probleme beteiligt als beim normalen Routen. Und beim normalen Routing hat man so ein bisschen schon verstanden. Es gibt da Tools, man kann so Boxen kaufen, die man ins Netz tut und die einem dann helfen bei der Diagnose. Das gibt es bei Multicast alles nicht, weil die Leute schon zufrieden sind, wenn sie überhaupt ein Routing hinkriegen. Das heißt, wir sind einfach mit den Protokollen noch nicht so weit, dass man eine Fehlerdiagnose überhaupt machen kann. Und selbst wenn man sie dann macht und jetzt gehen wir davon aus, dass sie richtig ist, dann trifft man vielleicht irgendeinen ISP, wo die Leute gerade alle im Bett sind, weil es nachts ist. Und der sagt dann, ja, habe ich jetzt aber keinen Grund, das zu beheben, weil meine Kunden sind gerade alle glücklich. Das ist die Art von Problemen, die wir hatten bei Multicast. Und deswegen sind diese frühen Feldversuche eingestellt worden.
Und wie geht es da weiter?
Also es geht so weiter, dass es einen Testbett gibt, wo die Provider sich zusammengeschlossen haben und wo man gesagt hat, wir vergeben Rondevue-Points und verpflichten uns dann auch für jeden, der anruft, das zu beheben. Aber das Billing ist halt immer noch nicht klar. Also die Berechnung, wer da will, wo für Geld gibt. Und deswegen ist das im Moment noch alles im Testbetrieb und kostet halt kein Geld. Das heißt, die Provider sagen alle gut, wir tragen halt die Kosten, die bei uns anfallen.
Das ist das M-Bone?
Das ist der M-Bone, genau. Und das machen halt auch viele Unis, wo die Kosten eh nicht so eine Rolle spielen. Das wird eh vom Staat gezahlt. Und es machen einige Provider, die genügend Geld haben für Forschung und Entwicklung, dass sie das mal kurz tragen können. Aber es ist eben noch nicht so weit, dass man da tatsächlich ernsthafte Sachen mitmachen kann, von denen jetzt mein Geschäftsmodell abhängt. Und deswegen ist es so ein bisschen schwierig, da den Übergang zu finden. Und es beschäftigen sich auch viele schlaue Leute damit, wie das denn überhaupt vonstatten gehen kann. Aber der Weg ist eben noch nicht frei und es gibt da auch noch so Detailprobleme, wie dass es da nicht ein Routing-Protokoll gibt, sondern es gibt sogar zwei ganze Klassen mit einmal drei und einmal zwei Protokollen drin und die sind auch nicht kompatibel zueinander. Das heißt, man muss sich da weltweit dann auch einigen, welche Protokolle man spricht. Und wenn man sich nicht einigen kann, muss man Wege finden, wie man diese Protokoll-Wolken verbinden kann. Wolke kommt daher, dass man immer so schöne Diagramme malt, wenn es um Netzwerke geht und die sind immer wie Wolken aus.
Das Internet ist immer die große Sau.
Ja, Moment, ich meine jetzt, die Verfügbarkeit ist die nächste Farbe. Nehmen wir mal an, ich will jetzt mit dem Radiosender an den Start gehen. Dann sagt mir Felix jetzt, ja, ich kann also Multicast nutzen. Sagt mir aber auch, du musst erstmal meinen Provider, muss ich erstmal dazu treten, dass er das irgendwie unterstützt. Und dann muss ich mich auch noch darum kümmern, dass es irgendwie Leute bei anderen Providern empfangen können. Und das erste Problem ist schon mal, wobei man sich da nicht mit einer aufgesetzten Struktur helfen kann.
Genau, das ist der M-Bone. Der M-Bone ist nicht tatsächlich im Internet, sondern es ist ein Tunnel über die bestehende Internetinfrastruktur.
Das klingt vernünftig.
Das klingt vernünftig, aber auch Tunnel sind mit einem gewissen Wartungsaufwand verbunden. Und letztendlich ist es nicht so, dass die Performance überzeugt. Also eine der Hauptquellen für Transmissionen zum Testen war immer die NASA. Die hat nämlich ihre Shuttle-Starts immer wunderbar übertragen über den M-Bone. Und das haben sich dann auch ein paar Leute an irgendwelchen Unis angeguckt. Und dann kam von dem Bild so ein Drittel oder so an und der Rest war halt Neues. Aber man konnte halt sehen, NASA und ich bin jetzt hier weltweit aktiv. Das war so Internetgefühl. Aber so richtig, dass man sagen kann, Fehler, Freitransmissionen und so gibt es alles noch nicht. Und letztendlich, was Multicast vor allem gebracht hat im Internet bisher, ist die Erkenntnis, was man eigentlich alles noch braucht, bevor man da geregelt arbeiten kann. Und das ist auch einer der Hauptgründe, warum IPv6, also die nächste Version vom Internetprotokoll, warum die Standardisierung so lange gedauert hat, weil da immer wieder Sachen eingeflossen sind, an die man vorher einfach nicht gedacht hat. Also die Leute, die das Internetprotokoll erfunden haben, das sind auch alles keine Magier, sondern die kochen nur mit Wasser. Und die überlegen sich das halt am Anfang, und wenn dann später auffällt, dieses und jenes muss noch geregelt werden, dann dauert das eben noch ein Jahr länger. Also Multicast im Moment ganz klar noch nicht dafür bereit, dass man da sein Geschäftsmodell drauf aufbaut, ist eher ein Testspiel-Wett im Moment, aber wir nähern uns dem.
Aber wie ist das in firmeninternen Netzen? Da dürfte es noch eigentlich kein Problem sein. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie die Konferenz von der Chef-Etage einfach ins firmeninterne Hausnetzwerk einspielen will, dann sollte das auch ohne Probleme gehen.
Na klar, und das ist auch das Hauptanwendungsgebiet im Moment, also im LAN und in Netzen, die unter einer administrativen Kontrolle hängen, also wo ein Mensch oder eine Abteilung für zuständig ist, also sage ich jetzt mal als Beispiel das Post-Intranet, oder weiß ich, Daimler-Benz hat auch ein Internet, die können natürlich Multicast-Intran benutzen und tun das auch schon. Die Telekom fährt da große Feldversuche in ihrem Netz. Besonders geeignet ist das für Business-TV, ist so das Stichwort im Moment, wo der meiste Gelddruck mit generiert wird. Da geht es also darum, dass zum Beispiel in der Post oder in Banken so Fernseher an der Decke hängen und da soll in allen Filialen das gleiche Programm kommen.
Da geht es aber auch um Konditionierung in die Hirnwäsche. Ich war mal auf einer Veranstaltung, wo sie die Hypovereinsbank ihr Konzept vorgestellt hat. Da sind also alle Angestellten verpflichtet, morgens um acht oder irgendwann pünktlich anzutreten und sich dann eine Viertelstunde eben vor der Glocke das Hirn waschen zu lassen.
Die machen das im Moment noch mit sichem Transponder-Miet.
Sie wollen es jetzt so machen, dass die Angestellten die U-Bahn verpasst haben und dann entsprechend fünf Minuten später da sind sie das ganz eben. Deswegen wollen sie es eben auch über entsprechende Internet-Streams machen. Abgesehen davon, dass diese Transponder-Anmietung auch nicht ganz möglich ist. Das kostet viel Geld. Aber jetzt noch mal ganz kurz zum zeitlichen Rahmen von dem, über das wir hier reden. Nämlich der Möglichkeit, tatsächlich seinen Radiosender an den Start zu bringen. IPv6 ist ja abgesehen von wunschenden Standardisierungsproblemen möglicherweise auch irgendwann Realität.
Ich glaube, es geht jetzt immer schneller.
Ja, es geht immer schneller.
Also der Leidenzug ist da und das ist ja schon mal gut. Also man kann konzentrieren, im Moment ist es so, dass tatsächlich der M-Bauen in einem Umbruch ist, denn ursprünglich das überhaupt erste Multicast Routing-Protokoll, was es gab, ist schon über zehn Jahre alt, heißt DVMRP. Das ist überhaupt ganz tolle Abkürzung immer bei Multicast und überhaupt Routing-Protokoll.
Die du jetzt auch ganz bestimmt nicht gesetzt habtest du?
Nein, das muss ich jetzt nicht weiter erklären.
Also wenn ich fehle, hey, wir sind hier auf dem Radio.
Genau.
Jetzt gibt es einen wunderbaren Satz mit Folien dazu.
Und da gibt es eine URL zu und die lautet www.fefe.de. Das ist meine tolle Homepage und da sind unter anderem diese Folien gelingt. Also wer sich das angucken will, sollte sich die Folien angucken oder in einer der nächsten CTs ist da wohl auch ein Artikel drin. Egal, jedenfalls die Multicast Routing-Protokolle muss man nicht wirklich verstehen, um das Problemfeld an der Stelle zu verstehen, was einfach ist, dass die nicht kompatibel sind zueinander. Und DVMIP war das erste Protokoll und deswegen hat das Testbett natürlich am Anfang auch DVMIP benutzt. Und als das Testbett dann größer wurde, da liefen dann so täglich gleichzeitig höchstens so um die 10.000 Transmissionen, aber das ist ja schon eine ganz große Zahl. Das heißt, da sind auch eine entsprechende Anzahl von Leuten beteiligt gewesen, also mehrere 10.000 Router. Und da ist es dann nicht so einfach mal zu sagen von heute auf morgen, wir benutzen jetzt nicht DVMIP, sondern PIM, Sparse Mode, das ist das Protokoll, was im Moment benutzt werden soll. Das ist ein Nachfolger, viel neueres Protokoll, an dem wird immer noch umgefallen, das ist auch viel besser. Aber das Problem ist eben, wenn da 40.000 Router beteiligt sind oder 100.000, dann kann ich da nicht anrufen und sagen, ja mach doch mal oder einen Termin bekannt geben. Das ist sehr problematisch. Deswegen ist der M-Born im Moment im Grunde gar nicht verfügbar. Es gibt da ein paar Splitter uni-intern zum Beispiel und es gibt da ein paar Testnetze, wo irgendwie...
Wann würdest du denn prognostizieren, kann ich, ohne mich jetzt groß zu akkreditieren, weil im Moment besteht die Hemmschwelle doch darin, wenn ich ein Radio sein aufmachen will, brauche ich 2, 3 Sachen. Das eine ist eine Studioausstattung, die fällt auch bei Internetradio nicht weg, auch wenn man die natürlich im Heimgebrauch etwas günstiger machen kann. Und wenn man ein bisschen Qualitätsabstriche macht, jetzt nicht unbedingt inhaltliche, sondern technischer Natur, dann geht das auch irgendwie mit einer nur weniger am Ende. Aber dann brauche ich auch noch irgendwie eine Sendung, eine Broadcast-Struktur sozusagen. Und beim Radiosender ist das nicht unerheblich, Frequenzen zu mieten, weil die sind nämlich knapp.
Und Transponder, das ist alles teuer.
Und dann gibt es irgendwie noch Lizenzgebühren und Minister, die bezahlt werden wollen.
Dann muss man auch mit Radiosender zahlen, auch wenn die immer nicht irgendwie...
Ja, aber die Frage ist doch, wann ist der Zeitpunkt, wo ich jetzt ohne mich explizit akkreditieren zu müssen und eine Lizenz oder eine M-Bone-Nutzung irgendwie anmieten zu können, tatsächlich damit losgehen kann?
Das kannst du heute schon machen. Das Problem ist, dass einfach...
Innerhalb eines Teilnetzes.
Nein, du kannst es auch innerhalb vom Internet machen. Du kannst auch heute schon M-Bone-Zugang kriegen für Senden. Denn Senden ist immer viel einfacher als Empfang bei Multicast. Das heißt, Senden kann man heute schon, kein Problem. Tunnel kriegt man auch kurzfristig für morgen, für zwei Stunden. Ja, Live-Konzert, aber es gibt im Grunde keinen, der das...
Es schürt nur leider keiner zu.
Genau, deswegen ist das Problem einfach ein Moment, dass die Provider... Also das Internet ist ja doch so hierarchisch strukturiert. Das heißt, wir haben auf der einen Seite super dicke Glasfaser oder Satellitenleitung, den Backbone, wird so der Rückenknochen genannt, Backbone. Dann gibt es die ISPs darunter, die haben auch dicke Leitungen, aber deutlich weniger dick. Und dann gibt es am Ende die Dial-Up-User. Und die Dial-Up-User fahren fast alle Windows oder sagen wir mal ein paar Linux, Mac OS. Diese Systeme können alle Multicast. Das heißt, wir haben am Rand von dem Internet komplett Multicast-Support. Wir haben auf dem Backbone heute auch Multicast-Support, weil die Router da ständig geupdatet werden, weil einfach neue Routing-Technologien rauskommen. Im Moment ist es so, dass die Leute von ATM auf Wavelength Division umschalten, ist ja auch egal. Es gibt da ganz tolle Verfahren. Es geht darum, dass man über eine optische Leitung mehr Sachen rüberbündelt, indem man mehrere Lichtfrequenzen ausnutzt. Ganz toll. Da braucht man neue Hardware und bei der Gelegenheit sind auch in den Routern gleich Multicast-Supporte drin. Das heißt, wir haben auf dem Backbone Multicast und wir haben am Ende Multicast, aber die Provider haben alle keinen Multicast. Und das liegt gar nicht daran, dass die Hardware von den Providern das nicht kann, sondern dass die Provider den Business Case nicht sehen. Wir haben hier also ein typisches Hand-to-Hand Problem. Wir haben ganz viele Leute, die wunderbar Geld machen könnten, wenn wir Multicast hätten.
Und wir haben...
Ich denke, dass wir bei diesen ganzen Finanzierungssachen uns das auch noch mal ein bisschen später noch mal reden.
Das Hauptproblem ist einfach, dass die ISPs im Moment keinen Grund haben, Multicast bei sich anzuschalten. Und dass daher kein anderer ein Geschäft damit gründen kann, dass er jetzt Multicast Radio macht.
Eine Sache interessiert mich auf jeden Fall noch. Wäre man da so wunderbar, das Prinzip, Multicast basiert ja eigentlich auf über Flutum. Das heißt, da werden einfach Sachen losgeschickt und die kommen irgendwo an. Wie ist denn das mit diesen Denial-of-Service-Geschichten, den Distributed Denial-of-Service, wenn ich jetzt einfach irgendwas losschicke an die Leute? Das ist ja wunderbar, weil dann treffe ich nicht nur einen Server, sondern ich treffe eigentlich gleich alle, die dazu kommen.
Ja, das ist bei Multicast macht das alles noch viel schlimmer mit dem Distributed Denial-of-Service. Und letztendlich ist es so, dass von den IPv4-Adressen schon ein sehr großer Teil, nämlich mehrere Millionen Adressen, einfach reserviert wurden als Multicast-Gruppen. Und dass alle Routing-Protokolle, über die im Moment auch nur nachgedacht wird, pro Multicast-Gruppe und teilweise sogar noch pro Sender in einer Multicast-Gruppe Daten im Router speichern müssen. Das heißt, der Router bräuchte mehrere Milliarden Bytes als Hauptspeicher einfach nur, um diese ganzen Daten zu speichern. Und dann erwartet man am Ende vielleicht noch, dass der Router noch Teile der Daten zwischenspeichert, damit man nicht beim Sender verloren gegangen Pakete abholen kann, sondern beim Router. Das sind auch Gedanken, die gedacht werden. Das heißt, wenn man einfach die ganzen Ansätze mal zusammenrechnet und sagt, wenn alle Gruppen benutzt würden, gar nicht mit den Null of Service im Hintergrund, schon dann wäre in allen heute zu kaufenden Routern der Rang zu knapp. Und ein weiteres Problem ist, dass die Adressalozierung nicht geregelt ist im Moment. Das heißt, es gibt da ganz viele Internetadressen, die Multicast-Adressen sind. Und wenn ich jetzt eine Ausstrahlung machen will, dann gibt es kein Gremium, wo ich hingehen kann und sagen will, ich will jetzt ausstrahlen, gib mir meine IP-Nummer. Also bevor ich wegklicken kann, kriege ich von meinem Provider eine IP-Nummer. Aber die Multicast-IP-Nummer gehören keinem, der die verteilen könnte. Das heißt, im Moment ist das so, wenn jemand eine Ausstrahlung macht, dann greift er sich halt eine IP-Nummer.
Guckt, ob da was kommt.
Guckt, ob da was kommt, genau, und strahlt dann da aus. Aber langfristig geht das nun nicht weiter. Das heißt, wir haben da zwei, drei Probleme, die einfach fundamental sind. Und es gibt da unter anderem natürlich Probleme, dass es Kollisionen geben könnte, die man gut vielleicht ein bisschen beheben kann, indem man vorher guckt. Aber auch das Vorhergucken löst nicht alle Probleme. Wenn sich jetzt die Deutsche Bank zum Beispiel hinsetzt und annulnt, dass sie morgen auf LP15 um 16 Uhr eine Ausstrahlung machen und dann guckt halt kurz vorher jemand und benutzt sie dann, dann kann die Deutsche Bank nicht sagen, na gut, dann gehen wir woanders hin.
Oder benutzt es mit Absicht die Wahrheit.
Ja, oder benutzt es mit Absicht. Auch das kommt noch dazu. Also es gibt da sehr viele Detailprobleme, die noch nicht gelöst sind. Und bevor wir überhaupt anfangen, uns mit die Null-of-Service auseinanderzusetzen, muss man sagen, schon die normale Benutzung würde die Route heute echt überfordern.
Und damit kommen wir zu Nachrichten, die jeder versteht. Wie es aus Regierungskreisen weiterhieß, werden die 21 Geiseln auf einer Insel im Süden der Philippinen festgehalten. Spezialeinheiten der Armee seien bereits auf der Insel. Einige um die Angehörigen der Opfer des Seilbahnunglücks von Kavalese erhalten Schadensersatz in Höhe von je 2 Millionen Dollar. Das teilte einer der Opferanwälte mit. Bei dem Unglück im Februar 1998 hatte ein US-Militia-Jet das Kabel einer Seilbahn durchtrennt. 20 Skifahrer starben in der abstürzenden Gondel. Vorwurf, sieben US-Waffenhersteller und die Nationale Vereinigung für Skisport haben Klage gegen das Wohnungsbauministerium und verschiedene Politiker eingereicht. Sie werfen ihnen vor, mit ihrem Drängen auf verstärkte Sicherheitsmaßnahmen, die in der Verfassung verankerten, Garantien für freien Handel zu verletzen. Aufschub, der Flug der US-Raumfähre Atlantis zur Baustelle der Internationalen Raumstation ist heute zum dritten Mal in Folge verschoben worden. Als Grund nannte die US-Raumfahrtbehörde NASA Regen und zu starke Winde auf den Notlandeplätzen in Marokko und Spanien. Im Mai soll ein neuer Startversuch unternommen werden. In einem Fußball-Länderspiel trennten sich am Abend in Kaiserslautern, Deutschland und die Schweiz unentschieden 1 zu 1. Der deutsche Meister Alba Berlin unterlag im Playoff-Viertelfinale der Basketball-Bundesliga der Männer bei Brandhagen überraschend mit 63 zu 68. Es war das zweite Spiel nach dem Modus Best of Five. Das dritte Playoff-Finale um die deutsche Eishockey-Meisterschaft zwischen den Kölner Heinen und den München Barons endete 0 zu 3. Damit führt München in der Gesamtwertung mit 2 zu 1 und braucht nur noch einen Sieg zum Titelgewinn. Wetter. Heute Nacht meist klar bei 12 bis 8 Grad am Tag. Wieder heiter und trocken 23 bis 27 Grad. Verkehr. Keine aktuelle Meldung und gut, das war's für uns.
Kurz informiert Gerhard Ketterheim, euch vielen Dank.
Also wir haben vor wenigen Tagen darüber gesprochen, wir uns in der letzten Gruppe...
Ach du Scheiße, jetzt geht das schon wieder los.
Da muss ich hinhören, soll ich?
Hallo liebe Liebende.
Markus Maria Profitlich.
Auch ich werde dabei sein, dann sind wir schon zu viel.
Die Sat1-Wochen-Show live in Berlin.
Samstag, 27. Mai in der Waldbühne. Präsentiert von Pritz.
Was?
Chaosradio 49 ist hier?
Okay, und wir haben jetzt möglicherweise so grob den Plot geliefert, was passieren könnte, wenn das mit dem Multicast dann irgendwann mal implementiert, aktiviert ist und wenn die Providers sich auch irgendwie drauf geeinigt haben, dass es sinnvoll ist, es zu unterstützen, weil dann könnte die Welt ganz anders aussehen. Und die Welt könnte ganz anders jetzt sein, weil dann die knappe Ressource, Bandbreite im Sinne von Senderfrequenzen, die Radiosendern, die diesen hier das Überleben beschert, ja, vor allem hat man alles verhindert.
Ja, noch eine ganz andere, recht knappe Ressource ist nämlich auch das Geld, was nämlich viele Leute auch schon daran hin hat.
Geld ist eigentlich immer ganz viel da, es ist immer nur an unterschiedlichen Teilen gerade untergebracht.
Im Moment glauben die glaube ich gerade alle daran, dass das Internet sie reich machen wird und entsprechend laufen sie zur Börse und werfen sie.
Wenn man E-Commerce davor schreibt, dann... Ich hab das böse Wort gesagt, Chaosradio.
E-Fritz, E-Fritz. Genau, das kann man auch vom Comrad schreiben und am besten Linux in der Businessplan erwähnen und dann...
Ach Quatsch, Linux und ein bisschen mit einem kleinen Pinguin aufs Exposé.
Genau, genau.
Reicht völlig. Aber davon abgesehen stellt sich ja die Frage, wie läuft das, nehmen wir mal an. Wir können Multicasten, also als Netzteilnehmer, wir haben irgendwie eine 460-Kilo-Bit-Anbindung oder was auch immer und das geht jetzt. Und jetzt müssen wir aber auch noch irgendwie das Studio finanzieren. Wie ist denn das eigentlich hier bei Fritz?
Wie, wo, wer bezahlt ihr die Stromrechnung?
Das zahlen die Rundfunkteilnehmer, die ihre Gebühren, die GEZ-Gebühren einzubzentral errichten, das ist zentral und das gibt einen großen Topf, der dann ausgeschüttet wird. Nach welchem Schlüssel weiß ich nicht genau.
Wie viel Prozent geht da in die Verwaltung drauf?
Ich würde vermuten, der Schlüssel ist die...
Wir ermitteln Quoten, aber das ist für die Werbung. Der Schlüssel, nach dem es verteilt wird, ist, denke ich, die Fläche, also die technische Reichweite von so einem Sender.
Deswegen ist Fritz so weit verbreitet.
Deswegen hat Fritz so wenig Geld, weil in Brandenburg und Berlin vergleichsweise wenig Leute wohnen. Der Westdeutsche Rundfunk zum Beispiel hat eine riesige technische Reichweite und hat deswegen natürlich auch extrem viel Geld. Und dann haben wir noch einen Werbetopf.
Das ist dann eure Portokasse sozusagen?
Nee, das ist nicht unsere Portokasse, das ist wesentlich. Also wenn wir den nicht hätten, dann würde es hier Heulen und Zähneknirschen geben. Also das ist schon einiges. Wenn ich mich recht entsinne, irgendwann hat der Chef das mal erwähnt, dass das, was wir mit Werbung haben, macht um die 15% oder sowas aus. Ohne das könnten wir glaube ich gar nicht senden.
Genau, und bei den Privaten sind es einfach 100%.
Bei den Privaten sind es 100% und darum klingen die auch alle so, als würden wir S-Bahn durch dein Fanszimmer fahren, damit du auch immer schön aufmerksam bist.
Ja, ich meine, gut, genau so funktioniert ja auch Fernsehen im Moment. Man erzeugt eben Aufmerksamkeit, um eben die Aufmerksamkeit an Werbefirmen zu verkaufen.
Na und Internet auch.
Also Internet ist einfach kein Privatfernsehen. Internet gibt es ja keine Gebührenreinungszentrale.
Webklicken funktioniert genauso. Nur die Banner-Ads sind wirkhoch wirksam, die am meisten drehen, am größten drehen.
Ja gut, aber bei Webklicken ist es ja nur noch nicht so, dass ich irgendwie keine Chance hab und mir da irgendwie, beispielsweise, was weiß ich, Adrenalin irgendwie mäßig irgendwelche Webseiten mischiert werden, die ich dann angucke, sowie irgendwie Krimis auf öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender und auch auf privaten funktionieren.
Na eigentlich schon. Also inzwischen ist es so, dass die Zeitungen in Amerika, die Zeitungswebsites, dazu übergegangen sind, den Artikel auf zwölf Seiten aufzusplitten oder auf n Seiten. Und auf jeder Seite ist unten ein Next-Button und unter den Next-Button sind zwei Banner und oben auf jeder Seite sind auch zwei Banner. Das heißt, ob ich will oder nicht, wenn ich das durchlesen will, dann habe ich da Werbepausen. Und die Werbepausen äußern sich erstens natürlich durch die Download-Zeit und zum zweiten, dass ich die sehe, ob ich das will oder nicht. Gut, bei Web ist es jetzt so, dass man technische Möglichkeiten hat, um diese Werbedinger wegzufiltern. Aber letztendlich ist das Businessmodell das Gleiche.
Ja gut, aber nur bei den Betreibern, die das jetzt sozusagen als Medienunternehmen angehen und entsprechende Finanzierungsdrücke da auch gleich mitbringen. Also es sind ja die, die es irgendwie gewohnt sind, dass sie irgendwie so und so viel Kohle halt haben und das entsprechend dann auch übers Web reinholen wollen.
Aber wie ist denn das, wenn ich jetzt die Werbung ausblende komplett so und alle Leute blenden die Werbung aus, denn wissen auch irgendwann die werbenden Firmen, dass sowieso keiner mehr zuguckt und das heißt, die zahlen auch nichts mehr.
Dann bricht alles zusammen.
Man muss ja auch sagen, also historisch ist das nicht so, genau, historisch ist das aber nicht so gelaufen, dass die Leute gesagt haben, wir machen mal Web und gucken, dass wir da noch was reinholen, sondern historisch ist das so gelaufen, dass die Leute geguckt haben, ah, wenn wir Web machen, kostet das nichts mehr und wir erreichen mehr und dann können wir unseren Werbetreibenden sagen, wir erreichen viel mehr Leute, dann werden irgendwelche Zahlen erfunden, wie viele Leute da irgendwie rumklicken und deswegen ist auch eines der größten Streitpunkte und eine der unangenehmsten Sachen, wenn man mit Werbung Geld verdienen will im Internet, wie man die Werbung ausrechnet, wie man ausrechnet, wie viele Leute das jetzt gesehen haben. Also das mit dem Ausblenden ist im Moment überhaupt kein Problem, weil das deutlich unter 1% der Leute machen, obwohl es so Sachen wie Webwasher gibt. Aber der Unterschied ist doch der. Also was tatsächlich passiert ist, ist beim Spiegel, dass die gesagt haben, wir machen jetzt mal, weil das gerade alle machen und haben nicht damit gerechnet, dass da auch nur eine Mark rein kommt. Und im Moment ist es so, dass es ein tragender Teil des Haushalts beim Spiegel ist. Die haben dann 15 Leute einstellen können von dem Geld und machen immer noch Gewinn, ohne dass sie da irgendeinen Aufwand hätten, weil sie die Texte einfach direkt aus dem Printblatt übernehmen. Also im Grunde ist es so, dass die Leute sich freuen, wenn sie mit den Texten, die sie eh schreiben mussten, für ihre Printausgabe im Web auch noch mal abgreifen können. Der Enduser, bei dem kommt es ja ganz anders an. Der denkt, ich kriege hier was geschenkt und dafür muss da oben ein bisschen klipp wie Bunty sein. Aber im Grunde ist es so, dass die Zeitungen genau keinen Aufwand haben, da ein bisschen Web zu machen, weil nur die Kosten für so einen Server, die sind zwar für eine Privatperson immens, aber wenn man guckt, was eine Zeitung für ein Budget hat im Monat, spielt das einfach genau keine Rolle. Deswegen, für die Zeitung ist das gefundenes Fressen und wenn die Werbung da ausfällt oder, sagen wir, viel kleiner wird, dann ist das immer noch eine Nullnummer, weil da hat man fast nichts und kriegt trotzdem ein bisschen Geld, ob das jetzt viel oder wenig ist. Im Moment ist es so, dass alle Leute im Internet versuchen, mit Werbung unglaublich Geld zu machen, aber das war nicht die Anfangsintention.
Ja, und ich glaube auch nicht, dass sich das weiter harmet, weil wenn ich jetzt irgendwie losgehe und Radiosender vergleiche jetzt wirkliches Leben und Netz und im wirklichen Leben weiß ich, okay, kostet irgendwie illusorisch viel Geld und ich muss ja quasi Werbung oder irgendeine Scheiße machen, um die Kohle wieder reinzukriegen. Also in Amerika gibt es auch so Konzepte wie Talkradio, dass eben die Hörer den Radiosender finanzieren unter dem Motto, dass es irgendwie unsere Information...
Wie die Runde über 90er Nummer andere...
Nein, nein, nein, es gibt in New York... Das ist zum Beispiel der von der amerikanischen Hackergruppe, die machen da auch eine Radiosendung, einmal die Woche übrigens. Der Radiosender finanziert sich halt so, dass zweimal im Jahr rufen die ihre Hörer auf, irgendwie zu spenden. Da kommt denn New York ist halt eine große Stadt, da kommt irgendwie dann genug Kohle zusammen. Das ist zwar veraltete Technik, die sie haben. Und sie spielen nur Musik, die ich glaube älter als 15 Jahre ist, weil dann müssen wir keine GEMA-Gebühr mehr zahlen. Entsprechend irgendwie nur Walzer und so ein Unsinn. Aber Herrgott, darum geht es halt nicht. Sondern es geht darum, dann Kommunikationsmedien zu schaffen. Und der ökonomische Druck beim Aufstellen eines Webservos ist ja auch nicht mehr so groß wie jetzt bei einem Radio oder Fernsehsender. Und genau das wird sich ja auch im Netz verändern. Dass wenn ich irgendwie da einen Radiosender hinstellen kann, der eben nicht 5 Millionen Mark kostet, sondern irgendwie 250 Mark vielleicht, oder sagen wir 25.000 noch oder was auch immer, aber was verhältnismäßig erschwinglich ist, dann muss ich eben vielleicht gar keine Werbung senden. Dann kann ich vielleicht mal andere Konzepte wagen.
Aber die Frage ist ja noch mal, auch gerade jetzt, also auch wenn du meinst, dass die Werbung vielleicht ein bisschen in Auslauf geht.
Aber ich meine, das ist doch die Moment, teilen sich x Radiosender. Wie viele gibt es in Berlin?
34, 35?
Ja, okay, 35. Die teilen sich irgendwie einen gewissen Werbeetat. Und wenn das jetzt 350 Sender wären, weil jetzt sozusagen mehr Frequenzen gäbe, wie wäre denn das? Würdet ihr denn da nicht auch leiden?
Da würden wir ganz extrem leiden.
So, und das heißt, ihr werdet leiden in Zukunft. Okay, stellen wir das mal fest, die werden alle leiden.
Es sei denn, es kommt dahin, dass es eben gesagt wird, zumindest jetzt für uns Öffentlich-Rechtliche, dass jeder Rundfunkgebühr zu zahlen hat und nicht nur Leute, die es nicht geschafft haben.
Das heißt, die GZ wird sich irgendwie Maschinengewehre anschaffen?
Nein, die GZ wird wahrscheinlich wohl aufgelöst werden, weil sie auch rechtlich nicht mehr haltbar ist möglicherweise.
Wie willst du die Gebühren dann beibringen?
Nach Steuern.
Das wäre auch eine gute Möglichkeit, weil dann könnte man Werbung auch wieder abschaffen. Zumindest im öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk. Das wäre eigentlich begrüßenswert.
Nochmal zurück zu diesen Einschaltquoten im Web. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt ein Webradio mache und ich will da auch Werbung machen, weil ich muss ja eigentlich, also ich muss auch dann GEMA-Gebühren zahlen. GEMA ist ja das Geld, also das ist eine Musikspieler. Wenn ich Musik spiele, die irgendwie bei der GEMA ist.
Auch wenn ich ein unkommerzielles Projekt betreibe.
Das ist egal.
Das betrifft also, glaube ich, 99, 9% der Musik, die so verfügbar ist.
Ja, bei den Russen hier bin ich nicht so sicher.
Ich kann die Wertungsteste darauf biegen und die nehmen bei der GEMA, das heißt, die GEMA treibt das Geld ein für die Künstler. Das heißt also auch, die Musik, die hier bei Fritz gespielt wird...
Das Gleiche passiert auch mit dem, was wir hier reden. Übrigens, das ist dann die VG-Wart.
Genau, das heißt also, aber für alle Musik, die wir hier auch spielen, muss Fritz auch irgendwie abdrücken an die GEMA, die das jeweils an die Künstler weiter verteilt.
Und wenn ich als Künstler sage, ich will aber nicht zur GEMA, dann gibt es andere Möglichkeiten.
Es gibt da so noch andere...
Das ist aber noch eine Extra-Sendung.
Es gibt noch andere Verwertungsgesellschaften, die man dann nehmen kann, oder man macht es eben frei und versucht es selber beizubringen.
Gibt es doch kein GNU-GPL für Musik?
Mit Sicherheit gibt es das. Wenn du rüber gehst und sagst, du hast ein Studio, da stehen 150 CDs, wo nur freie Musik drauf ist, wo irgendwelche Komponisten sagen, okay, hier, mach mich daraus, machen wir unsere Musikbetten und so.
Oder ausgelaufen einfach, nicht?
Oder es gibt...
Ja, gibt es schon noch mal. Da muss man keine GEMA-Gebühren zahlen.
Worauf ich eigentlich hinaus wollte, ist, ich muss einfach diese GEMA-Gebühren zahlen. Ich hab auch vielleicht noch eine Stromrechnung und ein bisschen Leitungskosten. Selbst wenn ich mich über Modem einwähle, muss ich mich da trotzdem irgendwie ein bisschen bei meinem Provider blechen. Und irgendwie will ich diese Kohle zumindest wieder reinhaben, weil ich mach das Radio nicht zu Privatvergnügen, sondern irgendwie... Was ist mit der Bedürfnis? Selbst da musst du von irgendwas leben. Genau, es soll zumindest unter dem Strich Null sein. Das heißt, ich versuch da irgendwie Kohle reinzukriegen. Und die einzige Möglichkeit, die jetzt im Moment gangbar ist, ist es eigentlich, da ein bisschen Werbung zu schalten. Und wenn ich Werbung schalte, dann muss ich ihm schon auch noch wissen, wie viele Leute da zuhören. Wobei das auch...
Da hab ich mal jemanden von Forza kennengelernt, der gesagt hat, dass diese ganzen Zahlen, die da entstehen, Quoten, Zuschauerquoten und so weiter, alles Unfug sind.
Das ist halt diese GfK-Gesellschaft für Konsumforschung, die die ermittelt. Und das sind dann glaube ich so Testfamilien.
Und 1000 oder 1500 Leute.
Die haben ja so einen kleinen Empfänger noch auf ihrem Fernseher.
Das sieht aus wie so eine D-Box. Also eine Freundin von mir hat das. Das sieht aus wie eine D-Box und die registriert immer. Du kannst das Fernsehprogramm nur umschalten über diese D-Box. Also die registriert jedes Mal, wenn du umschaltest, welchen Sender du guckst.
Der gläserne Bürger, ja.
Frag mich nicht. Ein paar Mark 50 und Einkaufskunst. Ein Kostumschalt bei Otto von 50 Mark oder so eine Aufwandsentschädigung. Und das Schlimmste ist allerdings, auch wenn du die Glotze anmachst und dem Ding nicht sagst, dass sie die Glotze angemacht hat, das registriert es irgendwie. Und fängt dann an zu blöken wie bescheuert. Und dann gibt es noch diese GfK-Leute, die haben dann auch noch einen Scanner zu Hause liegen, wenn sie das wollen, und können dann die Barcodes der von ihnen gekauften Waren scannen. Und dann kann man auch ermitteln, was so gekauft wurde. Immer wenn ich die in Frankfurt besuchen gehe, dann machen wir uns so Späße 1000 Zwickers.
Weißt du, wie die noch machen.
Das wird immer schon uns schon.
Aber eines bleibt doch irgendwie unklar an der Stelle. Nämlich warum gehen die Werbetreiber überhaupt diesen Aufwand ein?
Weil alle dran glauben. Das war, was der Forza-Typ gesagt hat. Das funktioniert. Es ist eigentlich Schwachsinn, aber es funktioniert, weil alle dran glauben.
Das funktioniert ja auch nur, weil die Erwartungen.
Ziemlich einfach. Das heißt, für mich als Radiobetreiber sehe ich anhand von meinem Server. Da steht dann irgendwie, bei den bisherigen Sachen, Unicast. Alle verbinden sich direkt mit mir. So wie zum Beispiel auch jetzt mit Fritz mit dem Real Audio. Das heißt, ich kann direkt auf meinem Server sehen. Meinetwegen, ich habe jetzt 385 Hörer. Da steht dann halt konkret die Zahl. Das ist gerade das Problem, dass es bei Multicast eben nicht so ist, weil da sendlich puste ich einfach drauf los. Das ist genau das gleiche, wie jetzt im Radio auch ist. Wir sitzen jetzt hier und haben jetzt hier keinen Counter für jeden Hörer, der jetzt irgendwie gerade mal auf Toilette gegangen ist. Dann geht die Zahl ein runter und dann ist er wieder dabei.
Genau, online kannst du es nicht messen. Es wird dann eben so gemacht, dass Umfragen gemacht werden. Also wird tatsächlich rumtelefoniert, rumgelaufen und gesagt, welchen Sender haben sie gestern gehört?
Das Problem ist, dass dann auch der RTL-Moneyman rumläuft und die Leute dann sagen...
Das Problem ist, die Leute antworten in der Regel nicht auf die Frage, welchen Sender haben sie gestern gehört, sondern welches Plakat haben sie gestern gesehen. Also das heißt, je mehr du die Stadt pflasterst, desto mehr Nennungen bekommst du.
Prima, das erklärt einiges. Na gut, also beim Multicast ist es jedenfalls so, dass der Sender, wie gesagt, die Daten genau einmal ausschickt. Das heißt, er sieht auch nicht, wie viele Leute das jetzt gucken.
Gibt es anonymes Multicast?
Moment. Multicast heißt, dass der Sender zwar als Absender drin steht, aber er kann da auch einen anderen Absender eintragen, weil das UDP ist. Also Multicast ist nicht verbindungsorientiert. Das heißt, man kann da eintragen, was man will als Absender. Aber der Punkt ist eben, dass der Sender ja eigentlich wissen möchte, A, wie viele Leute gucken zu und B, welche. Also eigentlich will er das nicht wissen, aber der Werbe...
Ich meine, in dem Moment, wo ich da irgendwie Sternpunkt MP3 rausschicken kann, und zwar mit irgendwie nicht unbedingt, gerade meiner IP-Nummer, da interessiert mich das nicht wirklich, wer dazuhört, weil ich bin da nicht darauf angewiesen, da irgendwie Geld für zu bekommen.
Aber Real Audio, die haben das z.B. unheimlich interessiert, wer da irgendwie zu beruhen ist.
Genau, Real Audio interessiert das und vor allem, du musst dir auch überlegen, die Leute, die überhaupt in Frage kommen, dafür in dieses Medium einzusteigen, sind Leute, die traditionell im Radio-Geschäft sind und glauben, dass sie übermorgen arbeitslos sind, weil das alles obsolet wird, weil sie in Sterngelände sind.
Das könnte man jetzt auch nochmal mit den Hörern diskutieren. Glaubt ihr auch, dass die alle arbeitslos werden?
Ja, naja, aber gut, man kann ja weitergehen. Das heißt, die Leute, die davon ausgehen, dass die arbeitslos werden, die haben auch als Einzige den Leidensdruck, da Geld zu investieren, wenn nicht direkt klar ist, dass da was zurückkommt. Das heißt, die Leute, die das machen werden, gehen mit den gleichen Voraussetzungen daran, wie sie an Radio rangehen, nämlich, dass sie gerne wissen möchten, wie viele zuhören, wann sie eingeschaltet haben, wann sie ausgeschaltet haben. Und das geht mit Multicast prinzipiell schon, wenn man einen Unicast-Rückkanal benutzt. Aber das muss man nicht machen. Und der Kunde, der irgendwie nicht gemeldet werden möchte, kann bei sich eine Firewall installieren oder seinen Kleintakten, damit er nicht zurück sendet. Aber es gibt also keine Garantie und keine garantierte Methode, wie der Sender mitkriegen kann, wie viele und wer bei ihm zugehört haben. Und das macht auch ein paar Sachen interessant. Eine Sache gibt es noch, die bei Multicast die Sache interessant macht, nämlich traditionell ist es so, dass ich als Kunde bei meinem Provider pro Byte, was ich sende oder empfange, bezahle.
Also sagen wir mal pro Firmenkunde, also bei der normale User jetzt, der sich einwählt, der Zeit ist nicht mehr als eine Minute.
Na der Dial-up-User ist doch noch, kommt bei der Online natürlich.
Im Prinzip ja schon.
Also dieses Modell gibt es, der online macht das so, TDSL ist im Moment einer der wenigen Bandbreiten, großen Zugriffe, die machen das auch so, dass sie pro Zeit oder pro Traffic abrechnen. Und bei Multicast ist das aber so, dass ich theoretisch keinen Traffic verursache, bei einem Provider. Also der Provider zahlt nur für eine Leitung, nämlich für die nach außen. Die Leitung zu mir ist eine Telefonleitung, die kostet flett. Da zahlt der Provider gar nichts für. Das heißt, die Rechnung des Providers an mich geht normalerweise proportional zu den Kosten, die ich dem Provider verursache. Und wenn jetzt bei dem Provider zehn Leute per Multicast die gleiche Sache hören, also die gleiche Ausstrahlung hören, dann geht das über die Leitung zwischen dem Provider und dem Backbone nur einmal rüber. Das heißt, es wäre an der Stelle ungerecht, wenn der Provider von allen zehn Leuten sich das voll zahlen lässt.
Aber Kapitalismus ist ja niemals ungerecht.
Nein, das wollt ich gerade sagen.
Und dann wird das natürlich auch nicht machen.
Zweifelsohne, das wird am Anfang passieren. Das glaube ich auch. Aber es ist einfach so, wenn Multicast eine gewisse kritische Masse erreicht hat, dann werden die Leute anfangen zu rechnen und werden feststellen, dass manche Transmissionen einfach schon beim Provider da sind. Und für die wird der Provider dann Werbung machen, weil es im Interesse des Providers liegt, dass die Leute alle das Gleiche gucken. Das heißt, irgendwann kommen wir zu einem Geschäftsmodell, wo der Kunde weniger zahlt, wenn die Sache schon jemand anders guckt. Das heißt auf Deutsch, wo der Kunde anteilig davon zahlt, wie viele andere Leute zuhören. Das heißt, je mehr Leute zuhören, desto weniger zahle ich.
Ja, aber das heißt doch auf gut Deutsch, also das klingt für mich aber nicht so besonders toll, weil wenn die Mehrheit der Mitbürger blöderweise gerade RTL2-Scheiße guckt, wie ich nun aber zufällig gerade Anem TV aus Belgrad gucken möchte, dann hab ich irgendwie die Arschkarte gezogen, weil mein Provider dann sagt, ja Alter, dann lang mal in die Tasche, weil das ist Minderheitenprogramm, was du dir da reinziehst.
Genau.
Und dafür bitte Bares. Also das ist ja nur nicht unbedingt der Grad an zusätzlichen Freiheit, den ich mir dann irgendwie...
Moment, also grundsätzlich ja, ist so. Das ist auch nicht meine Grundvorstellung, dass das Billing so funktioniert. Aber selbst wenn der Provider voll abrechnet für dich, dann zahlst du immer noch höchstens so viel, wie du im Moment für einen Unicast-Stream zahlst. Und das machen die Leute auch schon.
Das heißt, es wird nicht teurer, sondern maximal billiger.
Es wird höchstens billiger, und das in den meisten Fällen, nämlich wenn jemand anderes das auch guckt. Das heißt, im Grunde ist das gut. Und jetzt kann man sich mal ausrechnen, was passiert, wenn ARD eine Samstagabendshow macht, die Millionen von Leuten gucken. Wenn jetzt mein Beitrag durch eine Million geteilt wird, dann kommt da im Grunde nichts mehr zusammen. Das heißt, der ISP kann da wunderbar verdoppeln, ohne dass mir das weh tut, dass es irgendjemandem weh tut. Und das wird mit Sicherheit auch passieren. Und dieses Geld kann dann entweder der Provider behalten, oder, was ich glaube, das wird am Anfang natürlich passieren. Aber grundsätzlich glaube ich, dass eine Finanzierung, eine Rückfinanzierung über diesen Kanal möglich wird.
Möglich, ja, aber wünschenswert.
Ich glaube auch, dass das wünschenswert ist, denn die Provider möchten gerne, dass ich ARD gucke, was 100 Millionen andere Leute auch gucken. Deswegen wird der Provider versuchen, mich oder die ARD dazu zu bringen, dass sie das weitermachen. Aber das ist doch eigentlich echt scheiße, oder? Ja, Moment. Also das heißt Scheiße. Das ist nichts, was wir umgehen können. Ich glaube, das Projekt einfach alles. Ich gehe davon aus, wenn der Provider feststellt, dass es da eine Ausstrahlung von ARD gibt, die eine Million gucken, und es gibt eine Spezialität, was weiß ich, Tiershow aus Süd-Was-Weiß-Ich-Was, was genau einer guckt, dann möchte der Provider gerne, dass alle Leute auch der eine ARD gucken. Das heißt, er wird erstens ARD gerne Kohle dafür zukommen lassen, wenn ARD fragt. Denn ARD wird einfach kommen und sagen, wir haben hier Kosten, wir möchten gerne bezahlt werden. Und entweder wir machen Werbung da rein, was natürlich geht. Aber ich meine, die Frage ist, zahlst du lieber GEZ oder zahlst du lieber über deine ISP-Rechnung, was irgendwie Pizzle-Puzzle-Beträge sind, weil eine Million andere Leute auch gucken. Ich glaube einfach dieses Finanzierungsmodell wird kommen, ob wir das gerne haben wollen oder nicht. Und letztendlich glaube ich, dass es nicht...
Das entspricht dann aber letztens schon irgendwie Pay-Per-View.
Und ich hab ja auch das Problem der Vorhaltung. Also ARD muss ja erstmal die Kosten tragen. Also ARD muss ja ein Programm produzieren. Und wenn dann keiner guckt, dann ist es etwas problematischer. Also dann hat die ARD das zum ersten und zum letzten Mal gemacht. Von daher wird ARD immer sagen, gibt uns Gebühren. Das ist unsicherer.
Nein, also das ist auch für die Zukunft gesehen. Also auf dem Weg dahin werden viele kleine Leute irgendwas ausstrahlen. Ich gehe jetzt auch nicht von morgen aus, auch nicht von nächstes Jahr.
Das heißt doch letztendlich, dass die Jagd nach der Quote sozusagen in diesem Fall nicht nur im Interesse der Sender, wie bis hier auch ist, weil sie dann nämlich anteilig Werbescheiße machen können, sondern eben auch der ISPs. Das ist ja noch nicht unbedingt das Modell, was mir so richtig toll die Laune bereitet. Ich fange jetzt an mit Minderheiten-TV oder Chaos-TV, was nächste Woche erst mal nur drei Leute gucken werden und entsprechende Kosten verursacht. Vielleicht ist es einfach nicht das Programm für die 80 Millionen.
Na klar, das sind auch nicht nur schöne Folgerungen, die ich da stelle. Was ich auch behaupte, ist, in dem Moment, wo wir dieses Billingmodell haben, dass der Kunde beim Gucken zahlt, weiß der Sender nämlich doch, wie viele Leute geguckt haben und wer. Das heißt, das wird auf jeden Fall kommen, weil das alle beteiligten Sender haben wollen. Und das heißt, da geht meines Erachtens kein Weg dran herum. Und das heißt, dass wir in Zukunft dafür geschlagen werden, bestraft werden, wenn wir Sachen gucken, die nicht so populär sind.
Also Artel wird richtig teuer.
Artel wird, naja, was heißt richtig teuer?
Moment, aber die ganzen Sachen, das, was wir jetzt besprechen, das kann noch nicht, also mal so Pi mal Daumennage, irgendwie was da an Beträgen zusammenkommt, auch zwischen dem Serviceprovider und dem Bidding untereinander, das sind doch irgendwie, denke ich mal, recht kleine Summen, oder?
Ja, natürlich.
Also das sind nicht plötzlich irgendwie 1, 5 Millionen Mark, die für die Produktion von einer großen ARD-Fernsehshow irgendwie notwendig sind.
Aber wir kommen doch trotzdem dann dahin, dass derjenige, der vielleicht ein bisschen besondere Musik hören will, ein Schweinegeld bezahlen muss, im Zweifelsfall, und derjenige, der Kaspar Mucke hören will, zahlt gar nichts, weil sie ja eh alle hören.
Genau.
Also das ist nicht wünschenswert.
Das ist nicht wünschenswert. Aber ich glaube, dass da kein Weg dran vorbeigeht. Und was ich auch glaube, ist, dass wenn wir erst mal durch die Hintertür soweit sind, dass ich dafür zahle, dass ich Sachen gucke, dann kann es durchaus auch sein, dass die Sender einfach das Unicast gar nicht mehr anbieten und dass ich dann keine Wahl habe, das zu gucken, außer über Multicast, und dass ich dann für den Traffic durchaus Premiumraten zahle. Das ist denkbar.
Okay. Wir haben jetzt erstmal noch ein paar Kurzmeldungen für euch. Und danach wollen wir mit euch, mit den Hörern ein bisschen darüber reden, was ihr denn so eigentlich senden würdet. Das heißt, wenn ihr euch jetzt irgendwie so hinstellt und sagt, ihr macht jetzt aus dem Radiosender auf, und was ihr euch wünschen würdet, um Radio zu hören, also im Internet an Radio zu hören, vielleicht auch an Fernsehen zu sehen, würdet ihr denn eure Webcam aufstellen und euch irgendwie vorm Computer sitzen oder beim Pickel ausdrücken morgens vorm Spiegel, denn irgendwie ins Web broadcasten wollen.
IS geht in die nächste Runde. Im Rennen um den Advanced Encryption Standard. Dem DS-Nachfolger wurde die dritte Runde eingeläutet. Im Rennen sind im Moment überhaupt nur noch Mars, RC6, Rindal, Twofish und Serpent, wobei Twofish und Serpent im Moment als klare Favoriten dastehen. Erfolgreiche Angriffe wurden insbesondere gegen den IBM-Kandidaten Mars demonstriert, aber auch RC6 und Rindal mussten federn lassen. Eine Entscheidung wird im Spätsommer des Jahres erwartet. Zum dritten Mal in einem Monat ging einem britischen Geheimnisträger Daten verloren, in dem er ein Laptop gestohlen wurde. Diesmal erwischte es einen Leutnant Colonel, dem der Laptop auf dem Flughafen entwendet wurde. Vorher hatte ein ME5-Agent in der London-U-Bahn seinen Laptop verlegt und auch einem angetrunkenen ME6-Agenten erging es schlecht. Aber auch die Amerikaner haben Probleme mit ihren Laptops. So war kürzlich ein Mitarbeiter des State Departments ein Laptop in einem Konferenzraum verloren gegangen, der bisher nicht wiedergefunden wurde. Der Laptop soll tausende von klassifizierten Dokumenten über Waffenschiebereien enthalten haben, unter anderem hochsensible Informationen über Quellen und Methoden der US-Geheimdienste für die Informationsbeschaffung. BSI-Richtlinien Das Bundesministerium für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik BSI hat Richtlinien zum Thema Distributed Denial of Service herausgegeben. Mit diesem Verfahren wurden in den letzten Wochen etliche Server im Internet lahmgelegt. Das Papier listet 15 Sofortmaßnahmen, mit denen sich Service-Provider, Administratoren und Endanwender dagegen wehren können, als Traffic Relay für solche Attacken missbraucht zu werden. Der Chaos Computer Club zeigte sich positiv überrascht von der Güte der Vorschläge, bei denen ISPs empfohlen wird, IPs-Proofing seitens ihrer Kunden zu unterbinden. Yamakawa ausverkauft Die von Chaosradio in der letzten Sendung empfohlenen DVD-Player der Marke Yamakawa leiden im Moment offenbar unter Lieferschwierigkeiten. Wir empfehlen Ruhe zu bewahren, die Geräte kommen bestimmt wieder in den Handel.
Vielen Dank, die Reiskötter Heinrich, Null Uhr Zwei.
So, wir wollen jetzt mit euch telefonieren, ruft uns an, stellt Fragen, sagt was und vor allem wollen wir von euch wissen, was wollt ihr hören, wenn ihr Internetradio einschaltet?
Was könnt ihr euch vorstellen zu senden?
Genau, wenn ihr irgendwie einen Internetradiosender seht oder irgendwie Lust habt mit ein paar Leuten was zu machen, was würdet ihr da senden? Irgendwie würdet ihr einfach nur ein bisschen nette Technomusik spielen oder andere Musik oder würdet ihr irgendwie aus Büchern vorlesen oder eure Oma interviewen, wenn es Video gäbe, oder es gibt ja auch Video, was würdet ihr da übertragen? Vielleicht eure Webcam auf dem Schreibtisch oder sonst irgendwelchen Dumpfhug oder jetzige Sachen.
Oder könnt ihr euch möglicherweise sinnvolle Konzepte vorstellen? Möglicherweise.
Trips-Hotline ist geschaltet.
0331 für Podstar, 70 97 110.
Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Hallo, also ich wollte mich eigentlich nur mal bei euch beschweren. Und ja, ich weiß, ihr hört sowas sehr gerne. Man versteht hier kein Wort, was ihr hier erzählt. Keiner quatscht dem anderen, was er gerade erzählt, dazwischen. Jeder versucht den anderen irgendwie zu übertrumpfen, was er mehr weiß. Das kommt mir hier vor, als wenn ihr hier lauter Politiker sitzt und am Ende hat man gar nichts mehr verstanden. Könntet ihr das nicht irgendwie ändern?
Dick-Size-Contest.
Wer hat den längsten, wer weiß.
Andy hat den längsten.
Also ich weiß nicht, fandest du das jetzt die letzten zwei Stunden tatsächlich so schlimm? Ich hatte eigentlich den Eindruck, dass wir hier schon ein, zwei technische Dinge...
Also ich frage mich, hast du das schon mal zugehört, weil das ist eigentlich immer so... Also das ist noch nie anders gewesen.
Also es war nicht sehr regelmäßig, weil ich den Termin immer verschlafe. Also ihr seid ja immer so ein bisschen...
Aber heute kam dir das besonders schlimm vor.
Aber ihr könnt ja auch mal die anderen fragen, was die dazu davon halten.
Ja, das tun wir ja.
Na eigentlich würden wir gern hören, was du gerne im Radio ausstrahlen würdest.
Ah, dazu fehlt mir die Kreativität. Mir fehlt da gar nichts ein.
Du bist da eher Konsument, ja?
Aber du findest auf jeden Fall unsinnig, was du sagst.
Ich glaube, ich brauche Fernsehen, glaube ich, und sowas.
Bist du denn im Moment bereit, sozusagen für ein vernünftiges Radioprogramm Geld zu bezahlen? Also richtig Spargeld, nicht im Sinne von Werbung angucken, sondern Geld zu bezahlen?
Grundfunkgebühren praktisch.
Naja, denn aber nur, wenn mir das Programm auch immer gefällt. Also bei Fritz ist es so, zum Beispiel. Eine Stunde gefällt mir das Programm wirklich voll cool und dann kommt da irgendein Techno-Quatsch und dann mach ich irgendwas anderes rein, weil das ist überhaupt nicht z.B. mein Monat.
Ja, aber schonmal, Rundfunk ist ein Massenmedium.
Ja, ja, ja.
Rundfunk ist ein Massenmedium und wenn du Rundfunk empfangen willst, dann bezahlst du dafür, also wenn du Radio empfangen willst, bezahlst du dafür im Monat 10 Mark. Du kannst gerne mal hier vorbeikommen, dann zeige ich dir mal, wie viele Leute hier, was für einen Aufwand treiben, um diesen Rundfunk möglich zu machen. Und dann sind diese 10 Mark eigentlich überhaupt nichts mehr. Und du hast ja auch bundesweit 24 Stunden am Tag die Möglichkeit, Rundfunk zu hören und hast auch eine relativ große Auswahl. Und das finde ich das eigentlich nicht unbedingt angebracht, zu sagen, ich zahle nur, wenn es mir gefällt. Dann überweis eine Mark für jede Stunde.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, du hast mich jetzt gefragt, ob ich bereit wäre, dafür zu bezahlen. Also ich bezahle im Moment nicht.
Ja, da gibt es sehr, sehr viele, die das tun. Und sich dann in der Sendung die Rundfunkgebühren finanziert, ist darüber beklagen, dass es Rundfunkgebühren gibt.
Nee, das ist in Qualität schlecht, was man ja ändern könnte, wenn mehr Rundfunkgebühren da wären.
Wenn alle zahlen würden, dann würden wir hier richtig schön Terror machen können.
Nein, nein, aber ich meine mehr so, wie diese Premiere-Wörter. Also dass man diesen, wenn es technisch möglich wäre, ich weiß nicht, ob es es ist, dass man den Radiosender Fritz jetzt voll digitalisiert irgendwie, weiß ich nicht. Das ist ja jetzt schon so. Also einer ist nur für Techno, einer ist nur dafür, der andere dafür, der andere dafür. Und dann würde ich wirklich nur den hören, der mir gefällt. Aber wäre das denn überhaupt noch Fritz? Und dann würde ich auch viel zahlen.
Dann wäre es nicht mehr Fritz, dann hättest du nicht mehr nachmittags die Auseinandersetzung über Hip-Hop und Techno, weil zwei Moderatoren mit unterschiedlichen Geschmäckern im Studio stehen.
Na gut, dann kann ich mich auswählen, habe ich jetzt mehr Lust auf Hip-Hop, dann mach ich den Kanal rein und wenn du nur die Musik willst, dann kannst du auch bei einem CD-Shop die Sachen runterladen.
Also das sieht man ganz gut an Piep, so eine Sendung, wo am besten die Sendung laufen, wo wiederholt wird und wo der Moderator gar nicht zu sehen ist. Das kommt natürlich vor, dass die Leute einfach überhaupt keinen Bock auf den Moderator haben, die möchten nur die Beiträge sehen. Das ist im Radio sicherlich auch denkbar, aber das ist nicht die Art, was wir heute Radio nennen, sondern das ist CD-Laden. Also wenn du einfach auf drei...
Ich meine gar nicht, jetzt nur hintereinander da irgendwelchen Techno, meinetwegen abzududeln, sondern auch Informationen dazu, irgendwelche Interviews, alles, was damit zu tun hat.
Könntest du dir denn vorstellen, nehmen wir mal an, du hättest die Möglichkeit, dir aus einem Nachrichtenkanal und einem Musikkanal irgendwie ein persönliches Programm zurechtzusammeln, wärst du dann bereit, so zu sagen, anteilig dafür zu zahlen, also wenn du das zu sagen als Multicast-Struktur per Internet ins Haus bekommen würdest?
Joa, ich denk schon, also vielleicht einen Minutenpreis oder Stundenpreis.
Damit wärst du aber garantiert wesentlich teurer als mit 10-mal Grundfunktionen.
Ja, du würdest dir vorstellen, was das so kosten würde.
Es müssen ja keine 5-Marken-Stunde sein oder so.
Doch, das müsste es sein, weil du...
Zwei Fenniche in der Stunde sein.
Nee, guck mal, das müsste es sein, weil ich beispielsweise habe keine Ahnung von Hip-Hop. Wenn wir jetzt hier einen Hip-Hopper im Studio haben und ihn interviewen, dann habe ich hier irgendwo einen Kollegen rumflitzen, den ich kurz fragen kann, der aber gerade einen ganz anderen Job macht. Würden wir jetzt eine reine Hip-Hop-Sparte ausstrahlen, müssten da extra mehr Leute beschäftigt werden.
Na gut, aber das ist ja jetzt auch eine gute Frage hier. Man kann aber sagen, wenn wir 20 Fritz-Kanäle haben, dass dann der Personalaufwand mindestens mal 10 geht und dass dann einfach auch die Kosten hochgehen.
Ja, natürlich, selbstverständlich, aber...
Na ja, und dann musst du auch damit rechnen, dass du mal 10 zahlst, mindestens.
Das sind dann halt 100 Mark.
Na, 100 Mark wäre irgendwie die Differenz.
Ich weiß nicht, Holger, weißt du, was hier so eine Radiostunde kostet?
Ich weiß, dass dieses Projekt im Jahr kostet. Ich weiß nur nicht, ob ich das erzähle.
Also, es geht immer pro Stunde von einem 4-stelligen Betrag aus.
Na ja, dann wirst du ein bisschen öfter Werbung reinmachen.
Um Gottes Willen, das will doch kein Mensch haben. Du willst Radio hören, du willst Information und Musik und nicht Werbung.
Vielleicht kannst du den jungen Mann ja einfach auf die andere Taste da mit den Dauerwerbesendungen schalten.
Hallo, ich bin Basti.
Also ich hab bevor zum Thema noch mal ein paar Fragen davor an euch.
Kannst du ein bisschen lauter reden, Basti?
Ja, erstens mal, weil ihr vorhin noch über MP3 und so geredet hattet, ich bin der Meinung, dass sich Medien niemals durchsetzen, wenn sie nicht frei kopierbar sind.
Da haben wir ja auch gesagt, das ist genau unsere Meinung.
Und dann wollte ich noch mal sagen, dass die Berichterstattung über Hacker, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr jetzt mitverfolgt habt, in die Mauer oder Internetmagazin oder so, ist ja auch immer ziemlich lustig, zum Beispiel mit Internetmagazin, da gibt es so eine Rubrik Underground Internet, also wie steht mir das zu?
Wir lesen natürlich nicht alle schlechten Zeitungen, weil dir ergibt es ja mittlerweile eine so große Anzahl gerade im Internetbereich.
Aber das Blackbook habt ihr da gelesen.
Nee, ich hab einfach nicht die Zeit mir diesen ganzen Unsinn reinzusehen. Ich muss da mit Unterstellungsnamen zu abgeben, das ist schon irgendwie anstrengend genug. Lieber Hörer, ich hab deinen Namen nicht ganz gehört. Der Vorteil ist einfach, du musst dir den Kram ja nicht reinziehen. Du bist da nicht dazu verpflichtet. Dazu haben wir ja Internet, dass wir uns irgendwie aussuchen können.
Na die CC ist eigentlich stark im Bereich Anzug. Also die ist nicht so ein Sensations-Megfindig.
Naja, aber Hacker berichten die eigentlich eher selten.
Aber vielleicht hast du da noch was zum Thema zu sagen.
Ja, kann man bei diesem Verfahren, was die da gesagt haben, auch einen Proxy davor setzen. Zum Beispiel, wenn du zum Beispiel da eine Sendung machst und in Anführungsstrichen Tipps gibst, zum Beispiel von N-Koden von Premiere oder so weiter, kann das jetzt dann zensiert werden und dann könntet ihr doch auch herbeikriegen.
Gute Frage, ist Multicast zensierbar?
Multicast ist natürlich genau wie alle anderen Pakete zensierbar und diese Zensurmechanismen nennt man Firewall, wenn sie zur Sicherheit eingesetzt werden. Kann man natürlich auch benutzen, um Multicast-Konferenzen wegzufiltern, aber wenn jeder Bopel, der eine Internet-Deil-Ableitung hat, eine Multicast-Konferenz aufmachen kann und da irgendwie Content raustun kann, dann kannst du dir vorstellen, wie viel Aufwand es wäre, überhaupt nur zu ermitteln, wie viele Konferenzen es gibt. Es ist schon im Grunde mit heutigem personellem Aufwand der Kriminalverfolgungsbehörden nicht drin. Und dann auch noch festzustellen, wer da gerade über Hacker redet und wer nicht. Also da kann man vielleicht im Nachhinein einen Tipp kriegen und dann irgendwie irgendwas machen, aber eine Zensur halte ich für echt unrealistisch.
Und das hängt davon ab, wie viele Senders gerade gibt es?
Im Übrigen ist das so, dass ich natürlich meine IP-Nummer, auf der ich sende, frei rauswählen kann, und ich glaube, wie heute die Hacker-Websites natürlich auch verfolgt werden und irgendwie von links nach rechts ziehen, ist natürlich auch möglich, dann einfach auf einer anderen Frequenz weiter zu senden oder bei Multicast eben eine andere Multicast-Gruppe. Also Zensur ist da zwar technisch, theoretisch drin, aber ist nicht...
Aber eher längerfristig, also jetzt nicht kurz.
Also ich glaube auch nicht, dass das längerfristig passieren wird. Ehrlich gesagt...
Ich meine, dass die Maßnahmen auf längerfristige Zeit, wenn ich weiß, ein bestimmter Server steht irgendwo und der steht da auch noch die nächsten drei Jahre, dann kann ich den vielleicht irgendwie blockieren. Aber wenn ich weiß, der ist jetzt irgendwo für fünf Minuten oder für zwei Stunden da, dann muss ich halt irgendwie meinen Systemadministrator da antreten lassen und diese Sachen in die Firewall rein.
Also theoretisch ja, aber im Moment sind wir froh, wenn wir überhaupt hinkriegen, dass da eine Konferenz so halbwegs um die Erde geht. Deswegen ist das im Moment eher eine akademische Frage.
Basti, wir haben noch viele andere in der Leitung.
Naja, also nicht euren Lieblingsgeschmack sondern schon, was auch an Inhalten aber rüber kommen soll bei der Sendung.
Hättest du überhaupt Lust, ein Radio zu machen, wenn du jetzt die Gelegenheit hättest?
Ja, sehr gerne sogar. Ich hätte ganz spezielle Vorstellungen.
Wie sehen die aus?
Ich würde zum Beispiel, glaube ich, Musik spielen, die man nicht so kennt, also von Gruppen, die man noch nicht gehört hat. Einfach mal um zu zeigen, ich glaube, die Musik ist besser. Weil die Menschen mehr mit Herz spielen, glaube ich. Anstatt die Menschen, die irgendwie voll im Publikum stehen, in der Menge und sehr viel Geld verdienen damit.
Würdest du es auch machen, wenn du da überhaupt keine Chance hast, auch nur eine Bühne Mark fürzusehen?
Also sag mal so, ich würde mich nicht bereichern wollen, sondern eher irgendwie, um meinen Mitmenschen zu zeigen, dass es einfach Fun macht, dass es zum Fun machen so.
Hast du schon eine Website irgendwo?
Nee, leider nicht. Ich hab nicht mal Internet, aber ich dachte mir, das ist ja jetzt auch gar nicht so wichtig.
Nee, aber dann müssen wir dir vielleicht mal ein Konzept im Internet erläutern, nämlich wenn du da irgendwann ausstrahlst oder irgendwo eine Website machst, dann heißt es nicht, dass es irgend einer auch nur zur Kenntnis nimmt, dass es da was gibt.
Das ist ein bisschen schwierig im Internet.
Selbst wenn wir die Situation haben, dass jeder eine Ausstrahlung machen kann, dann musst du dir immer noch überlegen, wie kommen da jetzt die Leute hin?
Da nehmen wir den nächsten Grad, alles klar.
Das Chaosradio ist totgestorben, es war dramatisch.
Hallo, wer ist dran?
Hallo, Stefan. Schönen guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Gut, erstens wollte ich euch fragen, warum macht ihr nicht immer überlinungslustig?
Eigentlich machen wir uns eher über Windows lustiger als über Linux.
Über Windows machen wir eigentlich gar nichts.
Eigentlich machen wir uns über Windows und Suse Windows lustig. Genau, Coral Windows.
Caldera.
Also bevor wir uns über Linux lustig machen, ein bisschen schon ganz anders.
Nein, eigentlich mehr über die Linux publicity. Ich meine, okay, da habt ihr auch irgendwo recht. Eigentlich.
Da musste man darauf achten, wie die Aktien von Leuten abgehen, die.com und Linux in ihrem Namen haben im Vergleich zu Aktien von Leuten, die irgendwie verteilte Müllentsorgung, GmbH heißen.
Richtig.
Über was?
Ach so, und dann was ich noch bemerken wollte, Thema MB3, was ihr vorne kurz angeschnitten hattet. Wenn ihr euch wirklich mal vor eine Anlage setzt und das wirklich mal explizit durchhört, also nicht mit Kopfhörern, also ganz vernünftig, das ist wirklich zu hören. Bei welcher Bitrate? Bitte?
Bei welcher Bitrate?
Ich glaube, dass deine Soundkarte scheiße ist und dass du deswegen hörst, ob du da...
Nee, nee, das geht nicht um die Soundkarte, das geht direkt digital.
Also da hat er schon ein bisschen recht, weil wenn er dir eine Vinylscheibe vergleicht mit einem MP3, dann kommen hier die...
Ja, natürlich hörst du einen Unterschied zwischen Vinylplatte und MP3, das ist doch ganz klar, nur die Frage ist, was denn letztendlich besser klingt.
Meiner Meinung jetzt, ich sag mal, das ist eine Interpretationsfrage.
Also ehrlich gesagt, das ist so pauschal generell nicht zu beantworten. Es ist so, dass man natürlich, wenn man sich hinsetzt und zwei Eingabequellen hat, die das gleiche spielen und man hin und her und vor und zurückschalten kann und selber genau weiß, welches man hört und man macht das eine halbe Stunde lang, dann hört man da Unterschiede. Keine Frage, aber mir geht es inzwischen so, nachdem ich mehrere Jahre lang meine Sachen mit MP3 inkode, dass ich teilweise in originalen Musik-CDs glaube, MP3-Artefakte zu hören. Und wenn ich mir dann das uninkodete Original auf CD anhöre, sind die da auch drin. Deswegen, dass vieles davon, ich meine, wie der Name schon sagt, das heißt psychoakustisches Modell und das ist letztendlich eine Frage der Psychologie. Wenn man glaubt, da Sachen zu hören... Na klar, also das ist auch eine Frage, was man sich selbst einredet. Viele Leute haben einfach das Bedürfnis, sich selbst einzureden, dass sie da was hören müssen, weil das eben jetzt anders ist. Und dann hört man da auch Sachen, keine Frage. Aber es ist, wenn man tatsächlich einen Blindtest macht, bei dem weder der Vorführende noch der Höhrende weiß, was er hört, und der soll dann eine Zuordnung machen, dass das so das Einzige, was auch in der Medizin verwendet wird, um objektive Aussagen treffen zu können, dann hat man tatsächlich Testsituationen, in denen nichts gehört wird. Also wenn du das hörst, dann ist das gut, und dann ist auch dein Ohr vielleicht besonders gut, aber im Allgemeinen ist es nicht so.
Ich sag ja auch nicht so, dass das jetzt unbedingt eine Rolle spielt. Also ich persönlich muss sagen, wenn ich das jetzt meinetwegen im Auto oder sonst wo höre, ganz normal, dann spielt das eigentlich nicht wirklich eine Rolle. Weil wer sitzt sich schon hin und hört wirklich so genau Musik, das sind ja wirklich die wenigsten.
Vor allem hast du im Auto die Nebengeräusche gespielt.
Das nächste Ding.
Was man wirklich hauptsächlich hört, ist nicht Musik, sondern Musak.
Und davon abgesehen, was so diese Radiosachen angeht, besser als normales analoges Radio ist MP3, auch bei 96 Kilohertz sogar.
Dann ist hier Chaosradio.
Zu den Anwendungsbereichen, ich spiele in dem Bereich schon seit längerer Zeit rum. Vielleicht würde ich sowas von einer Anwendung wie CUCME mir vorstellen. Kennt ihr das vielleicht?
Vielleicht kannst du mal kurz für die Hörer, die es nicht kennen erklären, was es ist.
Genau, das ist ein Programm. Man kann es in einer Art sich wie Chatten vorstellen, bloß dass man da nicht seine Buchstaben austauscht, sondern Videobild und Ton übertragen kann.
Das ist im Prinzip eine Videokonferenz.
Genau, und das läuft auch ganz normal im Moderns. Da kann man bis zu zwölf Leute gleichzeitig sehen. Natürlich nur mit einem Bild, sehr klein pro Sekunde. Der Ton ist auch sehr mies, aber es funktioniert schon mal. Und das macht auf jeden Fall großen Spaß, finde ich. Und in die Richtung könnte es sicherlich eine Anwendung geben.
Aber du willst ja mit Multicast nicht mit 8 Millionen Leuten gleichzeitig Videokonferenz machen, oder doch?
Nein, es geht immer so von Radio und Fernsehen aus. Das entwickelt sich dann ganz anders. Ich würde so etwas eher dazu verwenden, um, was weiß ich, mit meinem Z-Freund aus Japan mir zusammen meine Lieblings-CD durchzuhören. Das sind dann irgendwie 5 Leute zusammen, die sich die Sendung ansehen.
Wir gehen deswegen von Radio und Fernsehen aus, weil das explizit das Thema der Sendung war. CUCMe ist zwar nett, aber solange du es nur mit 2 Leuten machst, spielt Multicast einfach keine Rolle.
Aber ich finde die Vorstellung eigentlich ganz interessant. Wir machen Chaosradio und wissen, dass es 12 Leute sind, die super interessiert sind. Warum soll ich nicht direkt mit denen kommunizieren?
Das ist auch ein bisschen das, wo sich es im Internet auch hin entwickelt hat. Wir sitzen da nicht mehr rum und gaffen immer die ganzen Tage Websites an, sondern wir hängen in Mailinglisten rum. Insofern hat er mich ganz unrecht, dass der Telefonie- oder Gruppenaspekt vielleicht sogar interessanter ist als der reine Ich-hab-der-Welt-etwas-mit-zuteilen-Aspekt.
Natürlich ist er interessanter, nur man kann einfach auch im Moment an den Multicast-Problemen sehen, dass das Problem, was am wenigsten gelöst ist, also das, was am allerwenigsten gelöst ist, wenn tausend Leute mit tausend anderen Leuten reden wollen oder eine Million mit einer Million anderen Leuten.
Oder drei mit einem.
Nee, das ist wunderbar gelöst. Also kleine Gruppen sind besser gelöst als große Gruppen. Denn im Moment ist es so, dass Multicast-Router pro Gruppe pro Sender Daten haben. Das heißt, wenn du eine Gruppe mit einer Million Sender hast, ist es genauso aufwendig, als wenn du eine Million Gruppen mit jeweils einem Sender hast. Das heißt, du kannst eine Million Fernsehkanäle machen und es ist gleich teuer von dem Routeraufwand her, als wenn eine Million Gruppe macht. Und die Anwendung für eine Million Leute reden miteinander, ist eine verteilte Simulation in einem Rechnercluster. Also das ist durchaus Sachen, die eine Rolle spielen. Aber das sieht im Moment gar nicht so aus, als wenn das jemand gelöst wird mit einer Million, die mit sich selbst reden. Und was am zweitschlechtesten gelöst ist, ist das Problem, dass eine kleine Gruppe so von drei bis sechs Leuten miteinander redet. Das ist zwar gelöst, aber man geht ja auch davon aus, dass dann entsprechend mehr solcher Gruppen existieren. Und diese Skalierbarkeit ist im Moment nicht da. Man kann davon ausgehen, dass man über die Backborn-Router im Moment so sagen wir 100, vielleicht 100.000, vielleicht auch 300.000, sagen wir 500.000 parallele Konferenzen hinkriegt mit dem Speicher, der da heute drin ist. Aber wenn jetzt jede Telekonferenz zwischen drei Leuten über Multicast läuft und da telefonieren ein paar 100.000 Leute miteinander, dann ist einfach das weg. Deswegen, im Moment sieht es nicht so aus, als wenn Multicast an der Stelle tatsächlich helfen kann, aber das kommt noch. Da arbeiten Leute dran, vielleicht wird das noch was.
Ich stelle mir das so ungefähr vor, sagen wir mal, wie die Weiterentwicklung vom Internet Relay Chat. Da haben wir ja schon irgendwie 1000 Leute, die mit 1000 Leuten reden in 1000 Kanälen.
Das ist aber nicht Multicast.
Ja, aber so von der Verbindung tut das Ganze dann eben damit Video und Audio laufen.
Also du gehst von der Anwendersache aus, das ist richtig. Aber die Frage ist, wie implementiert man das? Und auch der Internet Relay Chat läuft überhaupt nicht, wenn da mit Millionen reden. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das mal verfolgt hast.
Na ja, ich sehe es aber nicht ganz recht. Vielleicht funktioniert das technisch schon. Bloß haben wir da dieses Phänomen, irgendwie die Stimmung steigt, das Niveau sinkt und deswegen, wir haben eine Frage, kannst du dir denn auch inhaltlich was vorstellen, wo es Sinn macht, in so einer etwas größeren Menschenansammlung miteinander Bilder und Töne auszutreiben?
Ja, selbstverständlich. Ich würde das auch gerne haben wollen. Die Anwendung, die mir vorstehen würde, ist das virtuelle Museum. Ich meine jetzt auch den Hörer. Kleine Sache noch, warum ich mich so auf Radio und Fernsehen hier festgebissen habe, ist, dass das tatsächlich die Leute sind, die im Moment die Forschung bezahlen. Das heißt, das ist der Teil, der auch am ehesten gelöst werden wird. Deswegen beschäftigen wir uns damit, weil das der einzige Teil ist, von dem absehbar ist im Moment, dass es da bald eine Lösung gibt.
Was ihr meint, ist, würde ich sagen, der kommerzielle Bereich. Aber ich stelle mir eben den Großanwendungsbereich eben einfach so wie im Chat vor. Also wenige Leute mit wenigen Leuten reden, ohne kommerziellen Hintergrundsatzungen.
Du, es geht um die Protokolle. Das muss jemand bezahlen, dass die entwickelt werden.
Ja, aber warte doch mal kurz. Es geht doch auch um die Anwendung.
Nee, ist doch im Prinzip. Ich stelle es mir auch nicht viel anders vor als im ERC. Im ERC haben wir sagen wir 100 Bytes pro Minute. Das muss sich dann dermaßen erweitern, dass man da auch Megabyte in einer Minute rüberkriegt. Da muss jeder zu Hause eben nicht sein dünnes Modemkabel, sondern was weiß ich, ein optisches oder sonst was haben.
Aber lass mal die Technik kurz beiseite. Was stellt sie dir vor passiert, wenn Leute in so einer Menschenansage nur mit anderen Bildern und Tönen austauschen? Ich meine, beim ERC besteht ein Großteil der Faszination auch daran, dass man da irgendwie geradezu gezwungen ist, allen möglichen Scheiß in Worten auszudrücken.
Das eben die Anonymität hast.
Ja, das kommt dazu. Und in dem Moment, wo sich die Leute da alle nur noch die Zunge rausstecken. Also klar würde ich das zwei Wochen lang wirklich unterhalten finden, aber meinst du echt, das ist was für die Ewigkeit?
Naja, es ist dann auch verbunden wieder mit so einer Art Video und Demand und Music on Demand, bloß im Privatgesendet.
Also du meinst, die Leute würden sich wild was auch immer an Wildern schicken und was auch immer antönen. Und dann gibt es da auch noch diese Leute, die irgendwie glaube ich so kleine Apparate gerade erfinden, die das Ganze auch noch riechbar machen. Und das war sich dann irgendwie über entsprechende Chemikalien elektronisch angesteuert, den Geruch.
Die Nile of Service in ganzem Neuen.
Okay, ich glaube wir sollten mal, ich meine, da ist auf jeden Fall ein Gedanken wert so, aber ob es das so vom Goldenen von Eis, vielleicht gibt es da noch andere Konzepte.
Okay, hören wir uns mal ein anderes an, danke für deinen Anruf. Hier ist Chaosradio.
Hallo, mein Name ist Judith. Ja, ich wollte eigentlich nur anrufen, weil der Typ vorhin hat irgendwie gesagt, dass er das irgendwie so blöd findet, dass er immer durcheinander redet und er versteht überhaupt nichts mehr und so. Und ich wollte nur anrufen und sagen, dass ich das überhaupt nicht so finde.
Vielen Dank Judith.
Jetzt haben alle vier geantwortet, auch schön.
Danke.
Das war's schon?
Hast du denn eventuell noch ein Konzept für einen Radiosender? Weil jetzt mal perfekt sind wir ja sicherlich nicht.
Ähm, Konzept für einen Radiosender.
Was willst denn du machen, wenn du senden könntest?
Äh, nee, also so was ich jetzt so mitbekommen hab, in Berlin da ein bisschen rumzuschauen bei den Radiosenden, das halt einfach viel blödsinniger wäre. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass eine einzelne Person, ich mein, du hast ja vorher selber schon gesagt, wie viele Leute da mitarbeiten, das redest du, oder? Dass eine einzelne Person da überhaupt irgendwas brauchbar ist, auf die Beine bringen könnte.
Das dürfte sehr schwer werden.
Ich mein, okay, jeder hat so ein bisschen ein paar CD's, manche haben auch mehr, und manche haben halt ein paar interessante Freunde, mit denen sie dann plaudern können, aber das war's dann schon, oder? Ich mein, das ist so eine Woche.
Na ja, guck dir den offenen Kanal an, kennst du den? Nein, also du musst einfach davon ausgehen, dass in unserer Gesellschaft verdammt viele Leute sind, die ein enormes Mitteilungsbedürfnis haben. Die gehen einfach irgendwo hin, und wenn du denen die Gelegenheit gibst, dass sie Fernsehen machen, dann machen die das. Und auch wenn die überhaupt nichts zu sagen haben, dann stellen die sich dahin und irgendwie ziehen sich ein Kostüm an und erzählen irgendwas.
Das berühmteste Beispiel war in den Anfangszeiten vom offenen Kanal eine halbe Stunde Waschmaschine.
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Aber die Frage ist ja auch gar nicht, Multicast erlaubt dir eine Ausstrahlung zu machen, auch wenn sich das nicht lohnt, weil du zahlst nur für deine Ausstrahlung. Du hast keine Mehrkosten, die irgendwie beim Sender auftreten. Das heißt, du kannst auch ohne jeden Anspruch einfach irgendwie Kram senden. Und die Frage ist, würdest du das tun wollen?
Ja, ich würde mir das nicht antun wollen, aber wenn irgendjemand so was macht, dann würde ich da gerne mitmachen.
Kennst du Webcams? Webcams ist ja ein Mikrofon, das heißt, wo Leute sich dann da wie vorne sitzen, vor den Rechnern. Ich meine, wenn es jetzt jeder machen kann, stell dir vor, wir haben irgendwie 23, 5 Millionen Mal Big Brother live im Internet. Alle Leute vor ihren Badezimmerstiegeln, vor ihren Computern.
Aber die Frage ist, will ich denn wirklich wissen, was ich im Kühlschrank irgendwie meines Nachbarn anstehe?
Ja, sicher. Also ich meine, Big Brother, jeder redet doch drüber. Und da hab ich mir gedacht, viel interessanter wäre es doch zu sehen, was in einem tatsächlichen Leben von irgendeinem Menschen vorgeht, der jetzt nicht mit wildfremden Leuten in einen Container hockt, sondern der, was weiß ich, ja...
Du hast ein Bedürfnis nach so etwas zu sehen.
Ja genau, Telecam. Also von der habe ich immer gelesen.
Es gibt auch noch Tina-Cams in Deutschland.
Ja, also ihr kennt sie von den Mädels oder wie?
Na das machen vor allem Frauen, weil da die Finanzierung klarer ist.
Ja, das habe ich nämlich eh... Das habe ich mir kurz nicht überlegt, muss man dafür bezahlen? Und für diese Tanny-Cam? Ich meine, muss ich...
Ja, das ist übrigens auch sehr interessant. Also kurzer Einwurf am Rande bei Big Brother. Die haben ja auch alle Kameras irgendwie im Web. Das heißt, die kann man dann auch über diese Video-Geschichte angucken. Nur es gibt eben bestimmte Kamera-Ansichten, da musst du dann bezahlen. Das heißt, du musst dich dann speziell bei dieser Firma, die das betreibt, einwählen und das ist deine Telefonnummer. Die kostet ein bisschen mehr Geld. Ich glaube, so eine 190er-Geschichte ist das oder sowas.
Da musst du dich direkt dann einwählen.
Das ist dann die Infromotkamera im Schlafzimmer. Im Frauen-Schlafzimmer wohlgemerkt. Nicht im Männer-Schlafzimmer, nur im Frauen-Schlafzimmer. Das geht dann über die Karte, denke ich mal.
Bei der Tanny-Cam kriegst du ein paar statische Bilder, wenn du nichts sollst und wenn du da geupdatet haben willst, dann musst du da ein Abonnement machen.
Vielen Dank, Siegfried.
Das mit der Web kam mich noch bekannt, weil ein Professor von mir auf der Uni, der hat das in seinem Arbeitszimmer. Jedes Mal, wenn man zu dem geht, um den irgendwas zu fragen, muss man dann mit dem Internet sprechen.
Das ist ja cool.
Hast du die Adresse davon da?
Ähm, nee, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich ihm das irgendwie recht werde.
Wir machen gleich mal Nachrichten, vorher noch drei Takte Musik.
Danke.
Und damit haben wir es um 0.30 Uhr.
Debatte vor dem Appellationsgericht in Santiago de Chile hat am Abend die Anhörung zur Aufhebung der Immunität des früheren Diktators Pinochet begonnen. Zuvor lehnte das Plenum von 21 Richtern einen Antrag der Verteidiger ab, zunächst neue medizinische Gutachten anzufordern. Dies hätte das Verfahren um Wochen verzögert. Meinungen Russlands Kulturminister Schwitkoi schließt eine Rückgabe von weniger wertvollen Teilen der sogenannte Beutekunst an Deutschland nicht aus. Die Duma hatte zuvor einstimmig das sogenannte Restitutionsgesetz gebilligt. Es erklärt Kunstschätze, die im oder nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg von den Sowjets aus Deutschland weggeschafft wurden, zu russischem Eigentum. Vorwurf, Frankreichs Präsident Chirac hat die israelische Besiedlung des seit 33 Jahren besetzten Westjordan-Landes kritisiert. Nach einer Unterregelung mit Palästinenser Chef Arafat in Paris betonte Chirac am Abend, der Siedlungsprozess, der sich vorzusetzen scheine, entspräche wieder dem Geist von Oslo noch dem des Friedens. Aufschub der Flug der US-Raumfahrer Atlantis zur Baustelle der Internationalen Raumstation ist heute zum dritten Mal in Folge verschoben worden. Als Grund nannte die US-Raumfahrtbehörde NASA Regen und zu starke Winde auf den Notlandeplätzen in Marokko und Spanien. Im Mai soll ein neuer Startversuch unternommen werden. In einem Fußballländerspiel trennten sich am Abend in Kaiserslautern Deutschland und die Schweiz unentschieden 1 zu 1. Der deutsche Meister Alba Berlin unterlag im Playoff-Viertelfinale der Basketball-Bundesliga der Männer bei Brandhagen überraschend mit 63 zu 68. Es war das zweite Spiel nach dem Modus Best of Five. Das dritte Playoff-Finale um die deutsche Eishockey-Meisterschaft zwischen den Kölner Hain und den München Barons endete 0 zu 3. Damit führt München in der Gesamtwertung mit 2 zu 1 und braucht nur noch einen Sieg zum Titelgewinn. Heute Nacht Temperaturen zwischen 12 und 8 Grad, morgen wirds heiter und trocken sein. Temperaturen 23 bis 27 Grad. Verkehr? Keine aktuellen Meldungen, gute Fahrt.
Ja, vielen Dank Gerhard. Körter Heinrich, Null Uhr 32. Hallo liebe Brandenburger, die Berliner sind ja zahlreich erschienen in der Torstrasse 171, um diese Freikarten zu holen für die Starwars Aufzeichnung, um achten zu am 28.29.30. dieser Fernsehaufzeichnung beizuführen. Ihr selber könnt ja nicht in die Torstrasse kommen, weil ihr mit eurem beiden linken Händen nicht Auto fahren könnt, mit eurem Gesicht und auch in keine S-Bahn reinkommt, aber in ein Fernsehstudio wohl. Und zwar am 28. am 29. und am 30. Direkt nach Adlershof, die Aufzeichnungen beginnen um... Also, stimmt nicht fest. Also besser nochmal anrufen. Und zwar unter 030 243 45719. Ja, also Berlin 243 45719. Und dann einfach vorbeikommen. 28.29.30. Saufen bis die Schwarte kracht und Fernseh gucken.
Star Wars. Also bis dann.
Wir sind jetzt schon fertig. Alles gut? Chaosradio 49, ist das, was wir hier tun?
Wir reden über die Zukunft von Radio und Fernsehen. Es gibt jetzt den Fall, dass mit dem Multicast funktioniert irgendwann und jeder kann ein Radio oder Fernsehsender aufmachen.
Genau, wir wollen von euch wissen.
Und wollen es von euch wissen.
Was wollt ihr hören, was wollt ihr sehen, was wollt ihr aber auch selber senden, das heißt, ihr habt die einmalige Chance, macht ein Radiesender auf, was wollt ihr senden?
Dann fragen wir mal den ersten.
Oder auch, wie würde euer Konzept aussehen?
Hier ist Chaosradio Western.
Ich arbeite bei einem ISP. Welcher ist einer von den etwas größeren in Berlin? Vor anderthalb Jahren verkaufte er an Ami-Firma. Ah, alles klar. Dann kassieren sich alle gut. Und ich wollte mal noch zwei Aspekte beleuchten von dem Multicast. Einerseits hast du gesagt, oder jemand von euch, dass so was schwer zu feierrollen ist. Nee, zu zensieren, sagen wir mal. Es gibt allerdings ein anderes Problem mit Multicast. Man kann es sehr gut mit einem Denial-of-Service-Attack belegen. Weil, was zum Beispiel unnachheuer schwierig ist, ist dann mal einen echten Radiosender wie Fritz zu stören. Ich weiß ja nicht, was ihr so für Sendeleistungen habt, so 100 Kilowatt oder irgendwas. Da kann ich halt wohl als Bastler schlecht hingehen und gegen die 100 Kilowatt anstinken.
Das ist richtig, aber...
Wenn ich Multicast nur mit ein paar 100 Kilowatt raussende, kann ich auch über einen ISDN-Deil abmachen und auf dieselbe Multicast-Adresse irgendeinen Schwachsenden.
Oh, was du aber bei den Sender auch machen kannst, ist, dass du nämlich den großen Sendemast anpeilst und da...
Ja, naja, Moment. Ich finde seinen Einwand nicht ganz unberechtigt, weil im wirklichen Leben, wenn du da anfängst, mit so einem kleinen Sendemast oder mit so einem Auto rumzufahren, du weißt, was dann passiert, oder? Ich meine, wir alle kennen die Geschichten der Leute, die illegales Radio machen. Da kommen dann diese Peilwagen von der Telekom und dann kommen die Männer mit Maschinengewehren und dann ist es auf einmal echt ungemütlich. Und da hat das Internet schon noch ein, zwei andere Möglichkeiten.
Also das ist der eine Aspekt. Der zweite Aspekt ist, dass du sagst, man kann Multicast machen mit der Libyan-Source-Adresse, also mit einer beliebigen Absender-Adresse. Auch das ist leider nur bei dir im Lahn zu Hause möglich, weil die Provider, die untereinander Multicast austauschen, betreiben auch Multicast-Rooting-Protokolle, DVMAP oder MBGP, wo sozusagen ein inverses Rooting durchgeführt wird. Man versucht nämlich den Weg von dem Sender, von der Quelle, zum Empfänger zu optimieren. Man versucht einen inversen Rooting-Baum aufzubauen. Ich weiß, wir hören jetzt tausend Leute zu, die sich gerade am Kopf kratzen und sagen, was redet ihr denn? Aber ich denke schon, dass ihr bis vorhin raus will. Man versucht also einen inversen Rooting-Baum zu machen, der von der Quelle ausgeht. Nicht zum Ziel wie beim normalen Unicast-Rooting, sondern beim Multicast-Rooting macht man es genau andersrum. Dazu muss aber die Quelle bekannt sein, sonst funktioniert das nicht. Das heißt, Multicasting mit gespufften Thought-Adressen funktioniert nur sehr, sehr begrenzt, nämlich nur unterhalb deines Baums. Wenn du das hier in Berlin machen würdest, würdest du vielleicht alle Leute von deinem Provider noch treffen, aber niemanden sonst brauchst. Das ist nicht weltweit, das wird einfach nicht gehen. Ein letzter Aspekt war, das war schon etwas länger her, da musste ich den Salm hören, über die Billing-Geschichten von euch. Jemand von euch gesagt hat, hier wird immer noch nach Bytes bezahlt. Das ist zwar so, dass immer noch sehr viele Provider gegenüber ihren Kunden das abrechnen.
Wir haben auch explizit von den Kunden geredet. Wir haben explizit von den Kunden geredet. Also nicht, dass die ISPs an das abrechnen.
Das sind die Sachen, die die Provider untereinander abrechnen. Kein Provider, selbst die in Deutschland, rechnet mehr untereinander über Bytes ab. Das kann auch gar keiner machen. Es gibt auch gar keine Verrechnungsbasis oder sowas. Da werden entweder kosteneutrales Peering gemacht. Das heißt, man schaltet in der Leitung, teilt sich die Kosten und man ballert Treffik hin und her und freut sich. Oder man macht es an solchen Peering-Punkten wie am D6 in Frankfurt, dass man einfach kosteneutral dort Daten austauscht und gut ist. Aber selbst wenn man jetzt nicht einen großen Transitprovider sucht und dort seinen Verkehr in die USA abkippt, wird der nur nach Megabits bezahlt, aber nicht nach wirklichen Bytes, die übertragen wurden. Also das ist schon längst passé. Wir werden das auch zum Kunden hin in Deutschland noch in diesem und dem nächsten Jahr sehen. Das kann ich euch jetzt einfach mal so mitgeben. Man sieht ja in anderen Ländern...
Also du meinst, dass jegliche Bandbreiten...
nach der Bandbreite bezahlt wird und nicht nach der übertragenen Menge, ne?
Also die Bandbreite pro Zeit jetzt.
Oder? Ja, also dass man sagt, du zahlst für eine Übertragungsbandbreite von durchschnittlich über einen Zeitraum von 24 Stunden von 512 Kilobit oder ähnlichem. Diese Modelle gibt es ja heute schon und werden auch von etlichen Providern in Deutschland schon angeboten. Und auch die Flatrate kann man sich inzwischen leisten. Selbst von der Telekom kriegt man inzwischen Flatrate für 2 Megabits im Preis von 10.000 Mark. Natürlich nichts für einen Privatmann, aber Flatrate von 2 Megabits ist schon okay. Manche Firmen oder auch Leute, die sich als TV oder Radiosender etablieren wollen, können sich das durchaus leisten. Was noch viel billiger ist, ist Kapazität, die man sich nicht nach Hause schleppt, über eine Leitung, die natürlich teuer ist, sondern Kapazität in einem Hosting-Center. Es gibt also schon 1.000 und einen Provider in Deutschland, die dir anbieten, dass du deinen Sender, auch deinen Real-Audio-Sender oder deinen Multicast-Sender oder deinem PC, dort hinstellst bei denen ins Rechenzentrum und dort wirklich die Megabits für einen Apple und einen iCrest. Dieser Faktor dort nach Bytes zu zählen und damit versuchen, irgendwie Geld zu machen und dieses Schema, was du vorhin beschrieben hast, so sagt, die mehr Leute zuhören, desto mehr teilen sich die Kosten. Diese neue Cost-Sharing-Modell ist spätestens dann, wenn Multicast ready for Primetime ist, ist nicht mehr aktuell, weil da nicht mehr nach Bytes gecharged wird.
Magst du denn da mal eine Prognose abgeben zum zeitlichen Wagen?
Für diese Flatrate-Geschichten?
Nee, überhaupt nicht. Multicast, das ist tatsächlich als Kunde auch bei irgendwie Berliner Unternehmen, die ihn auch sonst wo hin verkauft wurden.
Ja, die Berliner Unternehmen hatte Multicast und hatte doch Angeboten. Die Firma, die diese Berliner Unternehmen gekauft hat, ist da etwas konservativer.
Und was heißt das? Haben die das denn in ihren Business Cases oder in welcher Sprache, die auch immer sich untereinander ausdrücken, schon mal wahrgenommen, dass das möglicherweise eine fluffige Angelegenheit sein könnte?
In den Business Cases eher nicht.
Aber reden denn die Advents darüber?
Solche Unternehmen arbeiten extrem marktdruckorientiert. Die machen also nicht das, was irgendwie schlau ist, oder sind selber nicht sehr innovationsfreudig. Dass sie jetzt sagen, das ist eine geile Technik, versuchen wir jetzt ein bisschen zu pushen, weil das bringt auch das Medium insgesamt voran. Sondern die sagen halt, Multicast, das machen wir, wenn es einer bezahlt, wenn es einer kaufen will. Also es passiert in den Labs. Wir haben es hier auch in unserem Lab in Berlin und auch in den Zentralstädten, in den Zentrallaborsts, wenn man sie so mal nennen wollen, an der Ostküste USA. Wir spielen damit intern rum, aber es ist überhaupt nicht vorgesehen, das jetzt in nächster Zeit an den Kunden anzubringen. Man muss allerdings dazu sagen, dass das natürlich schon eine Ausnahme darstellt. Es ist in Deutschland zwar bei vielen anderen Providern ähnlich, aber wenn man mal über den großen Teich guckt und die Leute sind da schon ein bisschen weiter, dann kriegt man dort von den großen Chaos dort regulär Multicast. Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel Kunde bin bei Quest, ist ja ein sehr großer Chaos da drüben, dann kann man dort einfach sagen, ich hätte gern Multicast-Feed auf meinem Link. Die bieten das schon an regulär.
Ja, dann besteht ja Hoffnung.
Ja, es besteht durchaus Hoffnung. Also es muss wieder mal rüberschwappen über die Zeit. Und es müssen die halt einfach Leute nachfragen. Also auch gesagt, ich kenne ja hier in Berlin, von dem ich rede die ganze Zeit, die sagen ja auch nicht, dass wir das nicht machen, aber sie wollen da nicht Vorreiter spielen und sagen, wir machen das nicht, sondern wir wollen jemanden haben, der uns jetzt bezahlt.
Kennst du denn aus den Gebieten, wo das schon läuft, jetzt um mal zur ursprünglichen Frage zurückzukommen, schon Konzepte, die jetzt außerhalb von sowas wie innerhalb eines Business oder einer Bank oder so Hausfernsehen zu machen, da schon Konzepte, die tatsächlich eher so auf öffentliche Medien hingehen?
Ja, universitär Forschungszeugs. Wenn du mal guckst, in Embron, was es da so gibt, sind halt eben solche Institutionen wie NASA oder europäisch auch gegebenenfalls auch mal ESA oder so, die eben staatliche Forschungskohle haben, die sowas machen. Und ja, Universitätszeugs und so. Die machen auch richtig Fernsehen. Es gibt zum Beispiel gerade in Südstaaten, in Georgia zum Beispiel, gibt es zwei Universitäten, die Universitätsfernsehen so verbreiten und das auch öffentlich ins Embron hinaus glücken lassen sozusagen. Das heißt, wer von außen da zugucken will, kann da auch zugucken. Und das ist eigentlich reguläres Fernsehen, aber ist von der Natur her eigentlich eher öffentlich-rechtlich, war eben Universität.
Das klingt auch schon mal irgendwie, wie es passiert was.
Es gibt auch Leute hier bei uns. Bei uns in der Firma gibt es einen Kollegen, der benutzt es selber privat, die lassen wir aber leider nicht rausklicken. Der guckt nämlich in der Firma gerne Wart1-Fernsehen. Wenn am Mittwoch das Voyager läuft, dann zeichnet er das zu Hause auf mit seiner TV-Karte und Multicast es bei uns.
Aber ihr müsst ja irgendwie, glaube ich, aufpassen, dass er da nicht irgendwie auf geht. Das 19 Zoll Rack, was da steht, auf einmal GEMA-Gebühr zahlen geht. Oder GZ, Entschuldigung.
In diesem Sinne ist es ja noch eine geschlossene Benutzergruppe und ich weiß, dass die Firma für ihren Fernsehanschluss, den wir auch haben, dass wir da auch GZ-Gebühren bezahlen.
Ansonsten hätten wir das nachträglich noch angemeldet.
Die GZ-Leute sind ja wie die Krebsen, muss man ehrlich sagen.
Aber die Werbung ist geil.
Die Leute finden, was irgendwie nach einer Tür aussieht, kratzen, die da gehen und sagen Hi und ihr. Und die haben hier bestimmt irgendwo ein Radio rumzustehen oder so. Dann sucht man und findet auch eins und sagt... Das ist aber auch gut so.
Man muss die ja nicht in den Haus lassen.
Wenn es die GZ nicht gäbe, dann hättest du keine Sendung, bei der du anrufen könntest.
Dann würde ich jetzt auch keine Gebühren verbraten dafür.
Ja, verbraten.
Na, zahlt ja dein Arbeitgeber oder bist du zu Hause?
Nee, ich rufe von unterwegs an.
Also, dann wollen wir dich mal nicht mehr Geld kosten lassen, okay? Danke für deinen Anruf.
Ciao.
Wer haben wir da?
Ich wollte noch mal zu dem Hauptthema zurückkommen. Ja, genau. Ich persönlich würde sowas gerne mal machen. Vor allem jetzt über Themen, die mich mehr so interessieren, zum Beispiel Metal oder so. Weil ich finde, dass es da doch sehr wenig gibt im Internet. Und ich habe einen Freund, der macht gerade Radio über Internet. Die wollten sich abends immer mal hinsetzen.
Zum Chaos over IT?
Richtig.
Wir haben leider ein Problem, weil wir wollten eigentlich da auch ein bisschen Spielereien machen. So Echo-Effekte und sowas. Aber wir haben ja irgendwie nicht wirklich Internet im Studio. Deswegen, also die hören jetzt bestimmt auch zu.
Ich habe auch gerade das Problem.
Das klappt irgendwie nicht, weil wir hier irgendwie nicht diesen Stream von denen kriegen und da auch nicht so schön in uns hier schalten können.
Na ja, ich habe das Problem, dass mein Internet friedlich connectet.
Einen Echo-Effekt kannst du aber auch von mir kriegen. Jetzt sag mal was.
Test, Test, Test, Test.
Das ist aber viel zu kurz das Echo.
Jo, nee, das war es eigentlich schon, was ich sagen wollte. So Radio würde mir wirklich Spaß machen über Internet.
Danke, Fabian.
Chaosradio her.
Was?
Danke.
Ja genau, hier ist Chaosradio.
Ja, Ruhig, hab noch was vergessen. Microsoft ist scheiße.
Das hat uns jetzt geholfen.
Vielen Dank. Das war jetzt seltsam.
Ich mach grad nur Musik hier.
Hallo.
Hey, da ist ja doch jemand.
Dachtest du, es wäre aufgezeichnet?
Ja, könnte ja sein, so wie er das zusammen schuckert.
Na ja, du möchtest dich also beschweren.
Nee, in keiner Weise.
Achso, das klang so.
Ich bin ganz zufrieden mit der Sendung. Muss aber im Namen des Spiegel erklären, dass der Felix da überhaupt nicht recht hat, dass da irgendwelche defizitären Dinge abgeschrieben werden.
Das ist nicht so. Kannst du das da mal ganz kurz im Vollständigen zusammenhängen?
Ja, es ist nicht so, dass der Spiegelverlag dort irgendwie sekundär Abfälle in den Äther schüttet. Da sind wir dann ja auch nah am Thema, was man sich dabei vielleicht wünschen möchte. Sondern es ist einfach so, dass dort sehr viele Leute herumlaufen und online etwas produzieren und das nicht unbedingt konstruktiv, also nicht unbedingt im Plus vermerkt.
Also es gibt noch einen Bereich, den Spiegel online, der jetzt nicht durch die Printausgabe abgedeckt ist. Das heißt, es ist ein deutlicher Überhang an Artikeln. Das heißt, es ist richtig klar, da gibt es viele Leute, die da schreiben.
Ja, inzwischen gibt es das.
Na ja, also ich meine, Spiegel online hat ja damit angefangen, dass sie Sachen aus dem Heft auszugsweise reingestellt haben. Wenn der Mann, der da ohne Namen am Telefon ist, das vielleicht noch mal kurz bestätigen kann. Und ich meine, was aber bei Spiegel online ja nun schon auffällt, ist, dass wenn man die URL irgendwie eingebt www.spiegel.de, dass dann erst mal irgendwie unglaublich viele Werbebänner geladen werden und dann irgendwie ein bisschen Text.
Da gibt es ein schlimmeres Fokus zum Beispiel.
Ja, mag sein, dass es Schlimmeres gibt, aber ich will jetzt nicht über abschreckende Beispiele leben, sondern über irgendwie schönere Beispiele. Und die Frage ist, hat der Spiegel mal darüber nachgedacht, da dran was zu ändern oder ist das wirklich nur eine Cash-Kau für euch?
Er versucht es doch.
Und zwar wodurch?
Ja, indem er das Ganze vitalisiert.
Wie meinst du vitalisiert?
Relativ schnell darauf zu reagieren. Er versucht, Inhalte vorzugeben. Natürlich ist er modisch. Ich meine ja nicht nur modisch, ich meine ja auch noch Werbe anladen. Damit sollte man das sicherlich nicht verwechseln. Aber er versucht doch schon sehr deutlich klarzustellen, dass es eben auch online Inhalte gibt. Dass er dann natürlich in gewisser Weise den Medien hinterher rennt, wie das von RTL bis sonst wohin geschieht.
Aber ich glaube, Andis Kritik war jetzt ein bisschen mehr bei der Penetranten der Werbung, die der Spiegel online da anbringt.
Ja, wo tut er das? Bringt er mehr Banner oder weniger?
Naja, nicht unbedingt mehr oder weniger.
Ich war vorhin an die Follow Versions, also die Next Side, wo oben und unten irgendwelche Werbebanner stehen. Das kann man dem Quality Channel nicht unbedingt vorwerfen. Werbevermarktung des Spiegels.
Quality Channel? Ja, die Frage ist ja, ob man zwangsläufig auf diese Werbefinanzierung sozusagen gehen muss oder ob es nicht auch andere Modelle gibt. Also gerade jetzt, wenn wir die Hörerfahnsatz haben, wollt ihr nicht?
Na ja, eine Möglichkeit wäre ja zum Beispiel... Es gibt viele Versionen von irgendwelchen Suchmechanismen, die nicht werbefinanziert sind, sondern cashfinanziert. Das bedeutet also irgendwo über ein Paygate. Was wäre die Alternative?
Können, kann sich in der Spiegel online das vorstellen, dass die Leute dann eben nicht werbefinanzierte Seiten abrufen, sondern direkt für die Seiten bezahlen für die Information?
Na gut, das war immerhin informativ. Die Frage ist natürlich, ob diese Werbefinanzierung noch greift in dem Moment, wo irgendwie, aber sie greift ja auch im Moment noch. Insofern brauchen wir darüber nicht zu reden. Ich meine, ob Radiosender darunter so viel leiden werden, ist eben die Frage, weil wie viele Leute können qualitativ ein Radiosender machen, der in wie vielen Stunden sendet?
Sehr wenige.
Na, die Nutzen sind immer notwendig.
Es ist vor allen Dingen nicht finanzierbar, weil die Informationsquellen, die wir haben, die kosten natürlich auch ein Schweinegeld.
Kannst du da mal einen Fall sagen?
Nein, kann ich nicht.
Ich weiß sie nicht. Aber gut, ihr habt hier die ganzen Agenturen laufen.
Wir haben hier sämtliche Agenturen laufen. Wir haben natürlich auch Überspielleitungen quer durch die ARD.
Ja, um das Mind Game weiter zu spinnen, könnte man ja auch ganz klar davon ausgehen, dass Summa Summa um sämtliche TPA und Associated Press und sonstige Texte einfach einfließen. Die können ja eins zu eins digital einfach ins Netz gestellt werden.
Das werden sie ja teilweise.
Damit würde man euch auch wiederum reduzieren, im Sinne von muss das eine Radiosendung oder sonstiges sein. Das kann ja auch ganz normal in Schriftform erfolgen.
Ja gut, aber die Schriftform kann ich halt, während ich Auto höre, fahre oder so, nicht so gut mir gerade reinziehen.
Ja gut, dann verbalisieren wir das Ganze oder vokalisieren das. Also ist ja überhaupt kein Problem, das zu stopfen, also den Inhalt zu bringen, das ist auch kein Thema.
Aber wie selektierst du ihn?
Naja, indem ich entsprechende... Moment, ich meine, ein Redakteur, was ist ein Redakteur? Ein Redakteur ist jemand, der genau dieses Filtering...
Das ist selektiert, das ist selektiert im Senatierung, was ein User hören möchte oder sehen möchte.
Du hast völlig recht, aber dazu haben wir ja zum Beispiel, was wir machen, sind ja über E-Mail-Verteiler, das sind dann sozusagen virtuelle Gruppen, uns gegenseitig die Sachen zuschicken, die unserem gemeinsamen Interessensraum liegen. Das heißt, wir sind da alle unsere eigenen Redakteure, wenn du so willst, aber auch jeder der Redakteur für die anderen und umgekehrt. Also jeder Teilnehmer ist auch gleichzeitig Redakteur. Und damit haben wir keine fest angestellten Redakteure mehr. Und das Problem zumindest annähernd gelöst. Heißt aber natürlich auch, dass jeder sich ein bisschen umgucken muss, was da so rumschwebt und das dann weiter schiebt.
Ja klar, geht es denn jetzt um ein Contentmodell oder geht es um den User und woher weißt du, was der User hören will?
Naja, wenn ich irgendwie einen Spatenkanal aufmache sozusagen und sage, ich mache jetzt ein Radio auf für Nerds oder ich mache jetzt ein Radio auf für Journalisten oder ich mache jetzt ein Radio auf für Leute, die an E-Commerce glauben oder ich mache ein Radio auf für Leute, die nicht an E-Commerce glauben, dann kann ich schon gewisse Kulturräume abgrenzen und sagen, naja, das wird die Leute interessieren und das ist das in die Richtung, die ich will.
Ja, dann kommst du so langsam in der Konklusion wieder dorthin, wo wir am Anfang waren, dass der Spiegel durchaus in der Lage ist, beziehungsweise das versucht über tatsächliche Online-Redakteure, nicht wie Felix das gemeint hat, dass das irgendwelche Sekundärverwertung wäre, zu schauen, was interessiert die Leute. Dass da natürlich in der Relation zu dem Printspiegel Absprüche gemacht, werden. Das heißt, dass das tatsächlich lapidare Themen behandelt werden, weil sie eben schneller vergänglich sind als in einer wöchentlichen Print-Ausgabe. Das ist auch klar.
Ich denke, wir sind auch kurz vor Ende. Wir nehmen das jetzt erst mal auf und signieren noch mal darüber, wenn wir denn alle unsere eigenen Radio oder Fernsehsender aufmachen, wie wir den Unsinn finanzieren, den wir da betreiben und welche Modelle es da noch so gibt.
Das war das Chaosradio 49?
Ja, so ziemlich. Wir schaffen es vielleicht ja noch. Ja, ich glaube, jetzt ist das einfach so. Wir gehen jetzt hier mal eine URL an. Das ist einfach HTTPS www.cccde. Da gibt es auch im Zweifelsfall einfach HTTPS Chaosradio und ccde.
Leider völlig veraltet im Moment.
Nein, nein, nein, wir haben es heute geupdatet. Mensch, so schwierig ist das ja nicht mit dem Netz. Es gibt da auch ein paar Links dann vielleicht, wenn Felix mal seine URL-Sammlung rüberrückt.
Genau, da gibt es ja noch diese wunderbaren Folien.
Da kriegt ihr auch die technischen Infos. Und das nächste Chaosradio gibt es ein bisschen früher.
Genau, und zwar nicht am letzten Mittwoch im Mai, sondern am vorletzten Mittwoch, das war aber auch der vierte Mittwoch im Mai.
Mai. Und da geht es voraussichtlich um...
Also entweder über... Also entweder über Schulen und Internet, oder es geht über IPSEC-Geschichte, das heißt also virtuelle private Netzwerke, gesicherte Verbindungen untereinander.
Aber wahrscheinlich jetzt erst mal um die Katastrophe, Bildungswesen und das Internet.
So viel zum Chaosradio 49.
Und jetzt haben wir möglicherweise 50 Sekunden für irgendwelche dieser abgefahrenen...
Oh, hier kommt noch ganz... Also ich denke mal, dass hier noch ungefähr vier Minuten. Also je nachdem, ob Martin Petersdorf sich bereit erklärt, mit seinem Soundgarn drei Minuten später anzufangen. Gute Nacht Brandenburg, gute Nacht Berlin, gute Nacht Chaos Computer Club Berlin.
Okay, und wer natürlich noch irgendwie tolle Ideen für einen Radiosender hat oder ein Konzept-Hater, soll es einfach machen.
Ja klar, und Bescheid sagen, damit wir es auch hören.